So, jetzt sind wir wieder, ging schneller als gedacht, Passport am Start, mal gucken
ob das Stream überhaupt wieder richtig läuft, jetzt beeil, ich hab jetzt umgestellt, ich
hab jetzt umgestellt auf, ein bisschen mehr Bitrate, weil Passive Excitement ist halt
ziemlich Scroll Intensive und dann Pixel Sounds wie Sauna, das muss ja nicht sein, also schön
wer noch am Start ist, weiß dass es nicht so wahnsinnig viel interessiert, aber ein paar
fanden die Streams ja gut und wie gesagt ich will mir eh neuen Charakter levelen, wir fangen
an, das ist übrigens mein eigentlicher, nein ich will nicht mit dem Typ handeln, das ist
übrigens mein eigentlicher Farm-Charakter hier, machen uns jetzt einen neuen, ich hab
die letzten Leaks immer nur Witch gespielt, in ein paar Varianten, jetzt erstellen wir
uns mal einen Stealth-Charakter, also wir machen die richtig, es wird irgendwie so übelstes
Meta-Build, also irgendeine Mischung, also ich hab mir schon überlegt wie ich level,
ich hab mir angeguckt was zur Zeit so am schnellsten ist und wahrscheinlich level ich mir ein,
was ist denn das, ein Shadow heißt das glaube ich, Shadow Trickstar mit am Anfang ganz normal
bis level 28 irgendwie bisschen Bogenstells, dann Chaos, Bellslinger und am Ende mache
ich dann, weil ich das schon die ganze Zeit mal spielen wollte, Cock, Ice Nova, yep, aber
in dem Fall nur CoC, bisschen Gear haben wir am Start, bisschen Currency haben wir am Start,
aktuell für neues Gear habe ich 5 Exalted Orbs und 267 Chaos Orbs übrig, also da sollten
wir schon ein bisschen gescheites Gear für bekommen, aber erstmal müssen wir einen neuen
Char machen und den Kram leveln, Exit, Character Selection, so, straight und dann erstmal
gucken, dass wir auch den Sound laut genug haben, so, also ok, was brauchen wir, Shadow,
wir brauchen einen Name, wie sieht es denn aus mit Cute Chat, gibt es den schon, fuck,
Cute Chat gibt es schon, ok, Aja ja ja ja, ok Aja ja ist definitiv belegt, das weiß
ich jetzt schon, ja, wie sieht es denn mit Aja ja ja ja aus, Alter, warum ist das alles
schon vergeben, Cute Chat, ok, Cute Chat, nee, das gehört sich scheiße an, der Name
ist in Path of Exile vollkommen wurscht, aber guten Abend Chat, ansonsten nenne ich den
irgendeiner Abwandlung von Poggers oder so, französische Poggers, Poggers, die da denken
alle ich bin französisch und will nicht mehr trainen, Poggers Fr, nee, das kann man nicht
machen, nee, ich will nicht Poggers Fr heißen, noch irgendein guter Name für, Baschen, Alter,
Baschen, Baschen, Alter, heißt der jetzt, ok, exzellent, den Namen gibt es nicht, perfekt,
ok, Moment, mal kurz bevor wir anfangen, gucken, dass der Lautstärke stimmt, aber
die Game Sound ist ein bisschen leise, ne, ich spiele immer ohne Game Sound, aber für
einen Stream kann ich mal ein bisschen lauter machen, skip allen Tutorials auf jeden Fall,
also wie gesagt ich bin nicht der ultra krasse Speedrunner in dem Game, gar nicht, ne, aber
ich hab mir ein paar Sachen abgeguckt, der zu den letzten Zeiten, womit es halbwegs schnell
gehen sollte, mal gucken, legen wir los, ach Quatsch man muss den Gramm aufheben, ja stimmt,
gucken ob die Lautstärke ok ist, nee man hört gar nichts oder, glaub man hört gar
nix, äh, Master Volume, what the fuck, Master Volume ist voller Wandschlag, lass mal kurz
gucken, weil ich, ja jetzt glaub ich hört man was wenn ich was kill, die Musik ist etwas
zu laut, mal gucken, gucken wie der Sound ist, ich hab, mein Game ist halt null eingestellt
auf Sound, ne, übrigens normalerweise killt man hier gar nix, dann machen wir die Musik
aber die Musik ist eigentlich ok, ich brauche ein bisschen Musikbeschallung, weil ansonsten
kriege ich Anfälle, wenn ich jetzt 5 Stunden am Stück hier Passive Exile grinde, hast du
ein Bild, ja, oh Moment, ich muss mal ein Passive Building aufmachen, machen wir gleich
in der Stadt, also ich werd bis 28 irgendwie sinnloses Bogenstelltspielen und dann mach
ich nur noch 15 Meter Chaos Spellslinger bis, äh, keine Ahnung, 70, 75 und danach
versuch ich mal ein bisschen Gear zusammen zu kratzen für, äh, Coq, Ice Nova, eigentlich
brauchen wir hier überhaupt nix killen, ich mein, genug Currency hab ich am Start um
zumindest ein Budget-Bild zusammen zu, also was heißt Budget, wenn du Reddit glaubst,
ist ja jedes Bild was mehr als 20 Chaos kostet useless, aber Reddit ist halt Reddit, ne,
und das sag ich als relativer Noob in dem Game, aber Reddit schreibt dann auch viel
Bullshit wenn der Tag lang ist, äh, hab ich mein Skill nicht aufgehoben, kann das sein,
ich hab mein Skill nicht aufgehoben, WTF ey, ich kack nur, ich hab mein Skill nicht aufgehoben,
das will ich mir mal vor, aber ich brauch den Skill eh nicht, das gibt's nicht, ich
hab vergessen mein Skill aufzuleben, geht schon richtig gut los, ich brauch Leben, Leute,
wir fahrt, Kack W, ha, gucken wir mal, jetzt krieg 17 hier, oh ne, Scheiße, wo hab ich
mein Skill, ah, ich hab den Loot-Filter drin, ich hab den fucking Loot, jetzt weiß ich
warum ich da nix seh, ich muss den Loot-Filter noch rausnehmen, rennt der einem ewig nach,
guckt euch mal an, ah, easy, wir machen das ganz, wir machen das ganz jetzt einfach noch
mal, ich muss den Loot-Filter ändern, ich glaub ich seh nix hier drin, hier da, hab
ich nicht aufgenommen, doch ich seh was, was hab ich für ein Loot-Filter drinnen, Strict,
ne Strict ist eigentlich ok, Strict ist gut für einen neuen Char, gut, da steht mal Tobix,
9919, dankeschön, muss jetzt erstmal die Gegner killen hier, und vielleicht sollte
ich den Kram auch mal zocken, kann doch sein, dass man null Life-Frag hat, man hat null
Life-Frag, Alter, so, jetzt aber, lol, wie schlecht, Alter, wie schlecht, ja, zumindest,
ich muss mir gleich noch das Passive-Building raussuchen, was ich brauche für, weil aus
dem Kopf weiß ich's nicht, ich weiß noch so ungefähr, wo man lang muss, man nimmt sich
hier die Chaos-Nodes, geht man irgendwie hier nochmal kurz hoch, dann, mal gucken, mal gucken,
wie weit ich ohne Passive-Building komm, excellent Speedrun, perfekt, ja, das Game sieht überraschend
gut aus, findste, Alter, WTF, ich hab noch nicht mal das Ding aufgenommen, ich bin noch
nie, noch nie verreckt, Alter, noch nie, ey, diesem Scheißgewinns gibt's doch nicht,
wie schlecht, das Game sieht auch nur auf den ersten Blick gut aus, das hat ziemliche
Probleme, wenn mehr Gegner auf dem Bildschirm sind, kann man weiter raussuchen, nee, nee,
das war's, weiter raussuchen kann man nicht, Alter, world first hillhog death, jetzt aber,
gau, dafür sind wir schon Level 1, aber stoppen wir jetzt immer Level 1, wird Passive-Exile
werden, nur ein Update oder ein neues Spiel, angeblich, angeblich neue Engine oder großes
Engine-Upgrade, aber nachdem Endgame und sowas alles behalten wird, beibehalten wird, ist
wahrscheinlich eher ein größeres Upgrade, Zepter brauchen wir nicht, also ich hab Level
Equip auf einem anderen Char, allerdings, immer gucken, wie gut wir hier vorankommen
ohne Level Equip, mal schauen, so, also, was wir brauchen ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
wir brauchen jetzt erstmal, ist hier irgendwie was, nee, brauchen wir alles nicht, Zweifelsfall,
falls wir gar nichts finden, so, wir brauchen erstmal ein paar Gems, genau, also wir haben
das hier, lesser poison, wir brauchen irgendwas, stings arrow, wie heißt das, caustic arrow
brauchen wir, und pierce, aber pierce gibt's noch nicht, pierce gibt's noch nicht, pierce
gibt's erst später, ich glaub, pierce gibt's bei mercy mission dann, so, dann mal schauen,
ob der irgendwie einen Bogen hat, der dude, irgendeinen Bogen haben die nix gescheitert,
aber crap, sucked, irgendwas, irgendwas mit zwei, jetzt willst du irgendwas finden mit
zwei Sachen drin, naja, was für ein Build, also ich will später, will ich cast on crit
ice nova mal ausprobieren, das wollte ich schon letzte league ausprobieren, aber hab's
voll verkackt, leveln werd ich komplett, übrigens, wenn man mal seine spells richtig
legen würde, leveln werd ich mit acht bis achtundzwanzig hier mit Bogenstells und danach
spellslinger chaos, chaos spellslinger, so richtig, richtig metaslave-mäßig, kauft
den, ich hab nen tabula auf nem anderen char, ich hab alles am start zum leveln, ich hab
nen tabula am start, ich hab nen goldrim am start, ich hab movement boots am start, ich
hab alles am start, müsst ihr doch rüber mulen vom anderen char, eine nice vorbereitung,
ja, so wir brauchen Bogen, wir brauchen Bogen mit ähm, grünen sockel, ich weiß die krassen
speedrunners die machen das nicht, die krassen speedrunners die rennen durch, wir machen
jetzt, pass mal auf Leute, wir machen jetzt, huge, wir machen jetzt huge speedrun strats
machen wir jetzt, nachdem wir hier fertig sind, huge, huge speedrun strats, pass auf,
hab ich mir abgeguckt, massive speedrun strats, aber dazu bräuchte man nen gescheiten bogen,
wir gehen jetzt nämlich nicht zur mercy mission, wie das alle noobs machen, also inklusive
mir, ähm, sondern wir gehen jetzt direkt zurück, ähm, machen die eggs und gehen dann
zurück, gehen dann in die submerged passage und von dort im waypoint gehen wir zurück
und machen mercy mission, massive speedrun strats, excellent, fivehead, ja, ich hab übrigens
doch in irgendeiner kiste auch echt noch nen dreilink bogen reingelegt, ne, ne da gehts
dann nicht lang, ich muss erstmal die eier finden, wo sind die eier, so und wenn wir
als nächstes in die stadt gehen, muss ich mir das pass of building aufmachen, da ich
richtig skille, ah, da sind die eier, aiaia, könnte mal irgendwie nen bogen droppen, der
mehr als einen grünen sockel hat, ja arm, so und jetzt kommen die hyperspeedrun strats,
jetzt geht man nämlich hier oben lang, scheiß drauf, die geht doch, ein blaues pack, können
wir killen, blaue pack, spring, fat xp, auf, umkippen, so und jetzt gehen wir nämlich
hier oben rein, gehen in die submerged passage rein, gehen in den waypoint und gehen zurück
und machen die quest, big brain, speedrun strats, ich hab mir auch für mich mal so grob
aufgeschrieben in welcher reinfolge man was machen muss, das hab ich auf dem zweiten monitor
auf, aber ich hab nicht einmal drauf geguckt, so und jetzt gehen wir zurück an die coast
und jetzt haben wir irgendwie 2 minuten gespart, jetzt machen wir die quest und jetzt specken
wir die things hier erstmal, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich hier oben lang muss, chaos
damage, chaos damage, ja, irgendwie sind die maps gerade alle von rechts nach links, das
sind arabische maps heute, ich brauch nen bogen mit 2 grünen socken spiel, da kann noch nicht
zu viel verlangt sein, anscheinend schon, nicht erlaubt, gleich nochmal beim händler
mal gucken, übrigens die händler, die wechseln ihr inventar nicht nach zeit, sondern nach
level up, das heißt wer sich wundert warum die händler immer den gleichen grams haben,
dann liegt das daran, weil man noch keinen level up hatte, das hab ich am anfang auch
nicht gecheckt, wo ist denn der dude hier, der boss, der boss man, hab ich den boss man
übersehen, der boss man ist da normalerweise immer hier, irgendwo unten oder, wo ist der
boss man, user 32dl, ich hab doch vorher 2-3 stunden geschrieben schon und ich hab gefragt
ob ihr gucken wollt und es haben viele gesagt ja, ne der boss man ist da nicht, ja der boss
man ist immer unten rechts, ah hier, jetzt kommt der boss man, irgendwo hier, ah, ich
hab den boss man, ah, life flask, so boss man, zack, die sind halt, am anfang die halten
halt echt nix aus, ah, mana, mana, medicine chest, so, life flask, zack, mana flask,
so, und jetzt ist glaube ich der speed run trick, man geht zur character selection und
geht wieder rein, dass man in der stadt landet, ah, excellent, massive big brain, so, ok,
und jetzt holt man sich hier den ganzen krempel ab, quicksilver für speed, was gibts hier,
pierce support, exakt das brauchen wir, und nen skillbuch gibts glaube ich auch, ne,
gegen den crap was wir nicht brauchen, kann man sich für später schonmal holen, wie viele
stunden hast du insgesamt, eh, keine ahnung, ich hab jetzt ja ne ganze weile nicht gespielt,
bis zur vorvorletzten season, also ein account der ist in der beta erstellt worden, in der
beta 2013 oder so, so, also das game möchte mir keinen ordentlichen bogen geben, oh mein
bogen gibts bei dem anderen dude, da muss ich mal in meine kiste gucken, da hab ich
nämlich irgendwo noch was, so, bogen, ach guck mal, excellent, 26 dex, zack, perfekt, wie
viele dex fehlen wir noch, 23, ist jetzt euer ernst, ok, da muss ich doch ein level mit
diesem crap ding hier spielen, ok, aber ich hab schon einige stunden, also, keine ahnung,
5, ich weiß es nicht, aber, ordentlich, ordentlich, aber auch nicht mehr so viel wie ich früher
gegrindet hab, ich hab ja früher teilweise mmo's in 10 stunden am tag gegrindet, jetzt
mach ich das vielleicht 1 tag die woche, 10 stunden grinden, ansonsten nur weniger, ja,
ich hab übrigens was vergessen, man sieht, dass ich nicht der krasse speedrunner bin,
brauch ja noch mal ein movement skill, ich brauch noch eine runde, frost blink, purchase,
frost, frost, frost, frost blink, excellent, so, jetzt haben wir nämlich hier alles drin,
wir haben pierce support, poison support, aber wir brauchen bloß noch ein level up für dex,
das halten wir aus damit, ich hab gedacht du hättest nach dem fail von overwatch ne
ganze zeit lang gar kein spiel, ja hab ich auch, also ich hab wenig gespielt, ich hab
wie gesagt, ich spiel ja auch erst seit metamorph wieder aktiv hier, ich hab davor relativ viel
gespielt und wie gesagt, der account ist von der beta, sterben, boss, fisch, alter ungelingt
sind die games so schlecht, vielleicht haben wir, vielleicht haben wir glück, vielleicht
haben wir glück, nein haben wir nicht, kann ja nicht mal anziehen, aber nach overwatch
stimmt, nach overwatch hab ich wirklich nicht viel gespielt, so jetzt haben wir wenigstens
ein bisschen speed und frost blink, ja frost blink, frost blink können wir da wenigstens
hier rein machen, ne das ist das falsche, wait, frost blink, frost blink, so frost blink,
ok, so jetzt haben wir ein bisschen movement speed, sonst kriegste kompletter anfall hier,
oh mein mapping ist nicht drauf auf der mouse seh ich grad, ich hab normalerweise die flasche
auf der mouse, dass es schneller geht, so ich hoffe, kann ich jetzt den gescheiten bogen
nehmen, immer noch nicht, muss meine mouse richtig legen, weil ansonsten hier ohne speed
kriegste am rad, so trick 17 ist jetzt man sucht ledge, das hab ich mir auch bei speedrunner
dude abgeguckt, trick 17 ist jetzt man sucht ledge und geht dann da raus, je nachdem was
man zuerst findet, ob man zuerst findet wo es runter geht oder zuerst ledge findet, pass
auf leute nächstes jahr, pass of exile world world record hier, genau und jetzt geht man
durch bis zum waypoint, crab den waypoint und geht schnell wieder zurück, so weit von
der theorie her und ich muss meine mouse belegen, weil ansonsten krieg ich anfälle, wenn ich
immer das ding drücken muss, immer meine flask drücken muss, monkaS die machen zu viel
damage, ja aber overwatch war schon ein harter fail, overwatch war schon ein harter fail,
ich finde overwatch hatte so viel potenzial an sich als game und overwatch war auch richtig
gut gemacht, aber das handling von blizzard, wie sie dann im endeffekt auch versucht haben
das meta in dem spiel zu beeinflussen, also viel spaß hatte ich da nicht mehr dran, skillen
wir jetzt einfach mal und dann kann ich nämlich den bogen nehmen und endlich mal gescheite
gems rein machen, so und bei der gelegenheit gehen wir mal bei der maus rein und stellen
maus auf 5, äh maus, wo ist meine maus, das da, das da, mein wie ging das nochmal, wie
kommt man den kram nochmal belegen hier irgendwie ne, tasten, tastendruck, ne noch 4, bild zuweisen,
tastendruck 4, das hier 5, weil dann kann man nämlich einfach das mit der maus zünden,
das ist viel einfacher, äh du hast overwatch installiert, der kann ich verstehen, jetzt
war mir nichts ein bisschen damage, es ist nicht hier so rumgegräbse mehr, so jetzt kann
ich mit der maus auch meine flasks ziehen, ja jetzt geht das doch schon ein bisschen
deutlich angenehmer, ein bisschen speed hier, jetzt müssen wir die komische krabbe killen,
gun bash, wenn euch das interessiert, ihr müsst euch mal unbedingt mal einen guten speedrun
hier angucken von quasi null auf kampagne durch, die leute sind echt übertrieben krass,
vor allem wie gut die erkennen wie die maps aufgebaut sind, ich weiß nicht wie die das
machen, du hast da teilweise die jumpen hier übelst rum und wissen ah ich muss jetzt nach
rechts unten, weil sie irgendwie nen felsen gesehen haben, der chap steht und anhand des
felsens der schief steht erkennt man wo es weiter geht, total abgedreht, also da gibt
es richtig pro's, da ist das fisch, der dweller, hat sich ausgedwellt, so jetzt macht es gleich
ein bisschen mehr damage, wenn man das richtige zeug hat, sonst können wir alles zellen gleich,
alles zellen, so und jetzt ist glaube ich die speedruns threat, man geht in character selection,
geht wieder rein und dann geht man zurück ledge und macht ledge fertig, aber vorher
verkaufe ich meinen kram, oh ne jetzt nicht, hab ich gar bock krasse trading action zu
machen, so und jetzt wenn ich glück hab war ich schnell genug und die ledge ist wieder
neu geladen, nicht neu geladen perfekt, so wenn ich hier durch bin muss ich echt mal
mein pass of building aufmachen, weil sonst verskille ich mich, ey wir machen auf einmal
damage Sachen gibts, jetzt kommt dieses komische fisch hier, ich glaube den muss man gar nicht
killen, ich glaube die ganzen speedrun dudes rennen da immer dran vorbei, zumindest kann
da nix, also ich werd mal ein level gear rüber mulen gleich, weil ich wollte eigentlich mal
gucken wie schnell ich, wie schnell es klappt ohne, okay das ist relativ easy am Anfang
noch, wir müssen jetzt einfach immer weiter bis wir ins prison kommen, auch da unten spackt
die grafik aber, weil kommt der jetzt nicht erstens mit den schiffen noch, ne das kommt
später, aber wir müssen jetzt hier direkt durch, bomb ks, die raadtypen machen übelst
damage, echt, was gabs bei euch heute zum essen abends, dachte ich muss mich ja anstatt
mit bbq pitboys, musste ich mich ja mit toastbro zufriedengeben, ich glaube den dude muss
man auch nicht killen, ob das ist alles nur debated, schaschlik geht nicht schlecht, nur
müll, so und jetzt muss ich mal ein pass of building aufmachen, weil sonst hab ich keine
ahnung, ist das schon der fork oder ist das, woran erkennt man ob das der fork ist, ich
weiß gar nicht ob ich hier die richtige version drauf habe, ah das ist der community fork,
excellent, so wir brauchen irgendein build, irgendein pass of building, krillax dankeschön
für den sub, hat der einen pass of building link drinnen, nennen wir das import, ich bin
begeistert, ich hab es geschafft meinen ersten 5 level mich nicht zu verskillen, chaos damage,
chaos damage, ok wir machen erstmal chaos damage, erstmal damage und dann bisschen
life und leech, ja so machen wir das, vielleicht so ungefähr grob durchblick was Sache ist,
jetzt haben wir hier add lightning, das brauchen wir nicht, das brauchen wir später, irgendwas
zum anziehen, würtel oder sowas gescheites, ich hab hier aber noch zeugs in der kiste,
siehts, meine kiste ist äußerst aufgeräumt wie ihr seht, das ist noch vom leveling hier,
da hätt ich auch noch nen bogen drin, irgendwie billig gürtel oder so, ne, doch guck mal ich
hätt hier sogar noch nen dreilink bogen gehabt, lowlevel, also hier blickt man doch voll durch
in der kiste oder, ach brauchen wir jetzt eh nicht, also ich find schon das man da gut
durchblickt, so also was skillen wir jetzt, erstmal damage haben wir gesagt, damage erstmal
hier runter und dann hier rauf, chaos damage, exellent, kist fps genau, haben wir schon
ringe, es sackt aber, das brauchen wir nicht, wir brauchen ordentliche sachen, levels zu,
ich level jetzt erst mal bis 28, hier mit diesem bogen stellens weiter und dann mach
ich chaos bellslinger bis 70, 75 und dann wollt ich mir ein bisschen gear kaufen für
cast on grid, ice nova, hab ich letztens ein richtig nice build showcase gesehen, das wollt
ich auch mal ausprobieren, wollte ich letzte league schon ausprobieren, bin ich dazu gekommen,
ich hab ein bisschen budget übrig, also ich krieg's, ich krieg da zumindest nen halbwegs
budget build krieg ich zusammen, ich hab 5 exalts und glaub ich 270 chaos orbs übrig,
da krieg ich schon halbwegs was zusammen, genau was ich am anfang gesagt hab, wenns
nach reddit geht, na und wie gesagt, ich bin ja immer noch ziemlich der noob in dem game,
weil ich eh wenig gespielt hab, wenns nach reddit geht, ist jedes build, jeder build guide
der mehr als, keine ahnung, 20 chaos kostet, crap, was aber schwachsinnig ist, weil die
richtig guten sachen kosten halt einfach ein bisschen was und auch diese einsteiger guides,
wenn man damit später, also quasi high end maps machen will, fuck, wo gehts denn hier
hin, und das halbwegs schnell, dann braucht man da auch ein bisschen investment, also
mit irgendwie hier mit 20 chaos orbs kommst du nicht weit, außer vielleicht als noch die
ganzen summoner dinger komplett unnerfed waren, da konntest du wirklich mit fast nichts und
skeleton und sowas zum beispiel fast alles farmen, das war op, as fuck, hast du die season
auch schon gespielt, ok, ist super teuer, also ich hab mal geguckt heut morgen, so der
spur nach, also die rüstung wird wohl das teuerste werden, ah fuck, wo ist das ding
hier, die rüstung wird wohl das teuerste werden, aber ich hoffe mal, dass ich so mit
3-4 exhalts hinkomm, dass es gut spielbar ist, da ist natürlich keine super high end
chest mit explosive und gedöns drin, nee, ja ich würde gerne mit explosive chest spielen,
die sache ist plus die, entweder muss ich die selber craften, mir geht das harvest craften
mega auf den sack, also ich bin keiner der gerne harvest craftet, oder ich kauf mir halt
irgendeine billige explode chest, oder lass es ganz bleiben, wichtiger ist, dass ich reflect
immun auf meiner chest hab, dass ich mehr maps machen kann, aber irgendwas geschah, das ist
gut, das brauchen wir später, also mein main, leider kann ich die chest von meinem main
nicht verwenden, main hab ich angefangen als das, wo du gegner in die luft sprengst
und
Spellslinger, Volatile, Dead und und Cops Explosion oder ich weiß nicht wie das spell genau heißt
mit
Impulsar und
Impulsar, Sixsling und relativ gutes gear natürlich bei weitem nicht so das was da manche leute hier im stream am start haben
Und das geht halt durch wie nix ja machst du t16 maps und und lullst dir einen ab dabei
Außer bosse für bosse ist nicht so gut
Warum laufe ich so dumm ey ich habe die kampagne schon 30 mal gespielt gefühlt ich weiß eigentlich wo es lang geht
Aber wenn ich wenn ich chat gucken muss ist irgendwie
brain dead
Kennst du von früher noch wahl fireball nee das war die zeit wo ich nicht gespielt habe
Das war die zeit habe ich nicht gespielt also ich habe ich habe wie gesagt ich habe die beta gespielt
Ziemlich viel danach ein bisschen aber da gab es das ganze wahl zeugs noch gar nicht die kampagne ging auch glaube ich
gerade mal bis zu dominus
Ich war mal kurz ein portal dass der typ mich nicht owned
Gehst du fort
Hey gehst du fort pepo fett
Ja mach mal mach da mal weiter
Aber oh jetzt will das wissen
Jetzt will er es wissen
Müsste ein städt sein
Städt
Sterben please
Big sick heißt das nicht bick
Also wie gesagt das wahl zeugs gab es damals noch nicht und als ich wirklich angefangen habe ich auch erst wieder als meta
Morph rausgekommen ist da war es mir ultra langweilig und ich habe mir ganz alter was schon lang kein perso wechsel mehr gespielt
Als mit meta morf angefangen habe habe ich dann gar nicht mehr aufgehört
Was krepp
Ich mul mir gleich echt mal der feld hier rüber
Ich wollte ich wollte eigentlich mal gucken wie gut man hier durch kommt ohne die feld hier rüber
Ich wollte eigentlich mal gucken wie gut man hier durch kommt ohne level gear aber das ja mühselig erst
Ach quatsch das geht ja gar nicht lang
Aber es ist ein ganz guter indikator dafür wenn man ein ticken über dem level der zone ist
Oh
Ich bin relativ lau
Aber ich glaube ist ein ganz guter indikator dafür wenn man ticken über dem level der zone ist
ein ticken über dem level der zone ist
Oh, den gibaten wir jetzt guck mal kack, kack noob gegner
oder auch nicht das steigt nicht drauf ein
irgendwas mit movement speed eigentlich wenn ich richtig pro wäre was ich
natürlich nicht bin würde ich jetzt schon nebenbei nach gier gucken
aber ich brauche eh also ich habe letztens ein video gesehen speedrun in
glaube dreieinhalb stunden oder so bis kampagne durch aber der typ ist ultra krass
wusste ja mal den kenne ich den kenne ich ja das ist auch krass also in den run war
top tie-tie killer den ich mir angeguckt habe andere sind auch geil aber hier das
dreieinhalb stunden ist echt übertrieben heftig aber hier muss ich nicht lang oder
glaube ich muss runter aber dreieinhalb stunden für die kampagne ist schon
heftig und der macht das ohne gier muss man sagen also der fängt komplett bei
null an und und nur mit lud in dreieinhalb stunden ultra heftig ich brauche
wahrscheinlich sieben stunden oder so
haben wir schon
kurz gucken gibt es denn hier mana gehen und kill ist schon mal sehr gut mana
gehen und kill haben wir ihn haben wir ihn wohl liege attack damage liege das
live excel ok perfekt dann gehen wir erstmal hier hoch
gehen wir erstmal hier hoch increase damage live mana oder nehmen wir holen
das erstmal live liege ich kann kann ruhig mana flas drücken das juckt mich
nicht normale spieler brauchen im stück im schnitt eine stunde pro akt also
akt eins und zwei ich weiß es wirkt jetzt zwar nicht so wenn ich für mich
hier sitze oder ich auf chat gucke akt 1 2 inklusive 3 eigentlich auch kann ich
mehr oder weniger auswendig da muss ich dann mal großartig gucken
ich habe mir auch schon mal so einen mini guide für mich selbst geschrieben
wo einfach die wichtigsten steps drinne stehen
hier muss man jetzt den das schiff suchen als schiff suchen das slave grill
finden guck mal da geht schon hier das immer doch schon
das war gut hier dass wir das direkt gefunden haben direkt hier ein slave
grill item aufheben und dann fair graves also ich denke mal akt 1 und 2 und 3
bin ich halb halbwegs schnell mittlerweile weil ich den kram ganz gut
auswendig kennen danach muss ich ein bisschen mehr in meinen guide gucken
aber was bei den speedrunner halt übelst geil ist wie gut die map erkennen
und und die erklärer manchmal auch im stream so ein bisschen auf was sie
gucken das ist das ist echt abgedreht die erzählen dann so sachen wie ja also
ich habe jetzt gesehen der felsen der ist jetzt hier ein bisschen in den einen
felsen reingeklitscht und und daran erkenne ich dass der boss oben links ist
was aha alles klar ich hätte noch nicht mal den felsen erkannt
guck ja komplett falsch geraten
ja oder andere oder andere sachen dass sie dann sagen ja da ist eben so ein
graffiti auf der wand und daran erkenne ich die map geht jetzt eher tendierte
richtung rechts oder in die linke richtung jetzt wo das bornen vom boss ist
unser übelst geil also keine ahnung wie die hohohoho ist ja gut ja ja ist ist
gut boss ist gut
kaputt übelst krepp an
so ich meine ich könnte pressplate anziehen aber das macht mich so langsam
moment lebt er wieder ach das der andere duit oh excellent lightning resistance
ich bräuchte kold resistance für den boss fight klar
ja alle mal besser als dem miss den ich habe
alles besser als den miss den ich habe
strength maximum life mannere generation ist kommt hier ein bisschen
movement speed please plus r&g wobei plus r&g gibt es immer ein movement speed
ein bisschen life
aber alles alles zählen gleich
was hat man gesagt den da a life gehen und kill ex dann haben wir ja bald das
wenn wir hier hoch gehen und das kind meiner mana und live rack ja das ist
schön das finde ich das finde ich gut so machen wir das so
wo steckt fair graves jetzt eigentlich kann man auf der web gar nicht viel
falsch laufen weil entweder findet man den ausgang wo man später lang muss oder
man findet fair graves an die quest abgeben da unten ist er
kann eigentlich nicht viel schief gehen ich finde die späteren moment jetzt hier
lang die späteren akte ziehen sich immer so ich finde auch dass die erste
vier fünf ex sind irgendwie mit mehr liebe gemacht habe ich so den eindruck
ja also der rest wirkt halt auch teilweise extrem recycelt immer die
gleichen bosse ich meine die die diese diese drei hauptgegner die es da in der
kampagne gibt die kommen ja dreimal dreimal recycelt einmal normal dann noch
da noch mal und zum schluss noch mal so als abbilder also da haben sie es echt
übertrieben mit mit recycling so dass wir nur noch den ausgang finden
kommt mal das wird schwierig bräuchte ich bräuchte echt ein bisschen kälte
ress ohne kälte ress ist wirklich krepp
ich gehe mal in die stadt mein skillbuch abholen das ist übrigens ein das ist
eine sache wo die ganzen speedrunner ultra zeit sparen im vergleich zu so
casual noobs die gehen irgendwie nur zweimal in die stadt pro act also nur
wenn es sein muss flame das auch mal flame ich muss mal kurz gucken flame
das ja flame das so wenig in stelle ich dir mal vor viel in brauche noch 33
ja wahnsinn haben wir haben wir gleich kann ich kann ich gleich speck 35 richtig
3 hat auch ich für später hier irgendwas nähen essen streng kann ich
mit dem essen streng brauchen wir später ne also jetzt bin ich eigentlich richtig
erst mal die ganzen misst hier zählen
besser ordnen sonst selte ich noch zeugs was ich nicht zählen will
wenn ich da jetzt nicht drauf an so ich ich mul mir mal mein level hier schnell
über wo ist denn hier letzten char habt ihr in den 70er stelzer
der müsste noch level hier haben
der müsste noch level hier am start haben exzellent
da hat alles was man alles was wir brauchen hat er noch perfekt
na dann da kann ich es mal schief gehen
aus mein char a bashen alle
brauchen wir später noch weil er hat ähnliche skills wie die ich brauche an
die sind zu weit aufgelevelt so erst mal gescheites level hier anziehen zack
resis zack run speed zack skills wenn ich da was gilt brauche sehr gut so
brauche ein bisschen int muss irgendwo ein bisschen hinter kriegen dann nicht
dann skillen wir erst mal hier weiter also int perfekt zack flame-dash
wo bekommt man dann so eine einfach trading ist am ende der league sogar
relativ günstig letzte league habe ich zwei stück selbst gefunden total random
also entweder du lässt dir vom nick so eine geben aber das einfachste ist zu
trainen wenn der trade league ist die richtigen pros erfahren die sich den am
anfang von der league du kannst in platte aqueduct das ist act 9 in act 9 kannst
du das innerhalb ein paar stunden erfahren ja 10 13 13 13 14 chaos also zum
level lohnt sich wirklich wobei man sagen muss bei dem bild was ich jetzt
hier eigentlich spielen will ist das gar nicht so gar nicht so wichtig weil ich
komme auch mit vier links mit mit vier link aus allerdings er vorteil ist ich
brauche halt keine links suchen im endeffekt kann es einfach rein zocken und
gut ist ups das
übrigens als trade seite wird immer die offizielle nehmen früher hat man
links hier genommen poe trade aber die offizielle trade seite ist
mittlerweile eigentlich das beste
was für bild machst du ich sage ich level jetzt erstmal hier bogenstells bis
28 da mache ich chaos felslinger bis 70 und dann probiere ich mich mal an
caston grid eisenhofer
illuminator wieso was denn habe ich was übersehen kann jetzt nicht so sehr auf
chat gucken wie sonst
ein bisschen currency gespart also so ein budget ding so ein halbwegs budget
fähiges hier sollte ich mir zusammen kaufen können dann wird sich teuer an die
ja ich denke ich bin ich wird es nett also ich ich habe ungefähr also ich
habe gerade im stash aber ich habe noch sau viel zeugs was ich verkaufen kann
was einfach nur rumlegt wo ich bisher zu faul war also jepp cockbild genau
also ich habe fünf exils in der kiste und ca 270 chaos in der kiste ich kann
noch mal relativ easy drei exils aus seeds machen und wenn ich mal meine
ganzen kisten sortiere und den ganzen müll dann mal selle dann wahrscheinlich
noch mal 1 2 relativ easy also ich sollte ganz gut hinkommen natürlich ist
dafür keine super krasse ex explode resi und reflect chest und so was drinnen
die kostet ja allein schon 10 bis 30 exils sind wenn die ordentliche chest
wenn man die selbst kraften will das meine ich
versuchst mal ein bisschen bisschen mehr budget auf budget eine die waffen habe ich schon für
als nova
ich mag es nicht nixor das ist das ist total unterschiedlich viele leute sagen es ist geil
dann gibt es auch ein paar wie mich die mögen das nicht weil ich spiele am liebsten ich
finde dieses crafting einfach nur lästig aber auch für mich ist die li geil und ich finde
ich fände es gut wenn es eine ähnliche mechanik nächste lieg wieder geben würde weil richtig
kranke items sind erschwinglicher zum kaufen dadurch dass es halt einfach mehr gibt und
ich kann siehts verkaufen siehts verkaufen ist übelst nice einfach einfach maps fahmen und
die siehtsellen das bringt richtig richtig asche
ja als looks genauso mache ich es auch gerade
du hast aufgehört zu zielen weil es kein ziel mehr gab ja aber genau dafür sind die
leaks ja da ich ich wie gesagt ich habe es ja ich habe es ja früher gespielt noch noch da
gab es auch keine leaks und sowas da gab es auch kein walz und ich glaube bei dominoes hat es
aufgehört das war wirklich ein bisschen doof weil du hast halt ein gutes bild und hast dann oder
hast zwei drei gute chance gehabt das ding auch nur gut was mache ich jetzt aber durch das
liegsystem finde ich kann ich immer wieder alle drei dreieinhalb monate oder so wann eine lieg
kommt kann ich immer ohne probleme zwei zwei monate regelmäßig spielen halt mit regelmäßig
mein ich halt nicht jeden tag zehn stunden wenn ich jeden tag zehn stunden spielen würde hätte
ich hier wahrscheinlich schon sonst was an ihr und geduld am stand ich bräuchte irgendwas cold
resistance ja exzellent wunderbar cold resistance das habe ich gebraucht ja ja
egal geh mal weg cold resistance brauche ich für den fight jetzt jawoll 70 prozent da kann
da kann sich die olle gleich mal verpissen er da macht sie kein damage gehst du dann auf die
league challenges also mir reicht es wenn ich pro league keine ahnung eins bis vier karakter
mache mit abwechslungsreichen bilds da bin ich genug beschäftigt und dann höre ich so ungefähr
einen monat bevor league ende ist auf zu spielen und warte auf die nächste league das ist optimal
für mich wie gesagt ich kreinde keine zehn stunden am tag mehr wie früher ich mache das am
wocheinende unter der woche habe ich da keine zeit zu kein bock zu oder was auch immer oder
das ist ziemlich gut übrigens mal eine empfehlung als programm richtig geiles programm poe awaken
trade damit kann man sich damit bekommt man ein overlay wo man schnelle preis abfragen machen
kann ich meine ist mir nur gerade eingefallen weil ich gesagt habe das ding ist nicht schlecht
insgesamt gesehen ist das amulett absoluter crap ja aber nur mal so zum zeigen download
portable ich zeige es euch mal das ist wirklich nice poe lurker habe ich nicht
ich habe auf meinem anderen account habe ich noch ein paar trade addons also für für den
browser trade addon für browser und hallo ganz mal auf geht und dieses ich habe vergessen
wie es heißt dieser trade helper der dir anzeigt wo in deinem stash den trade was einer kaufen
will ist ja ist gut monac s rap virus ist raus ist jetzt gestartet genau da drücken
einfach alt d oder so ich habe es bei mir auf alt d eingestellt aber wahrscheinlich ist es hier
nicht auf alt d settings sondern alt die control die aber ich habe es auf alte eingestellt und
jetzt kann man preischeck machen von den items wie gesagt ich weiß dass das nix wert ist aber
das ist das ist ultra praktisch da kann man direkt direkt preischeck machen auf gegen die
offizielle trade api was man so für items kriegt da kann man zum beispiel okay mein tabula was kriege ich
dafür so so 12 bis 15 chaos sehr praktisches tool was wenn du mit dem lurker auf der trade
seite anwesten möchte wieder sofort ok muss wir mal angucken so jetzt werde ich erst mal sterben
das ist das ist richtig sick kassel das ist richtig gut das kriegt man halt erst mal auf den sack
ließ sterben das wird leider ein bisschen schwieriger
ja da kommen die starcraft skills durch hier stutter step oder auch nicht fast
ich verrecke hier
ich spiele ich kein hardcore
vielleicht verrecke ich doch nicht ich habe ich habe ja massig cultress eigentlich dürfte ich nicht verrecken
easy easy
act 1 fertig hat das tabula das hat nichts das hat nur 6 link zockelt also das ist wirklich nur
zum level und die ersten maps zu gebrauchen du hast halt null defense mit dem ding es gibt
auch noch ein paar leute die hauen da wal orbs drauf dass du plus skills drauf hast und so was
das ist ein bisschen teurer aber braucht man eigentlich nicht ich will ehrlich gesagt will
ich einfach nur schnell 28 werden dass ich auf mein eigentliche skillung also auf mein eigentliche
sache um um switchen kann mit gems weil dieser bogen stelz geht mir schon echt auf dem kick
wenn es jetzt auch ganz gut damage macht mittlerweile
aber in der ersten aktenprobe nein du brauchst eigentlich bis zum schluss kein 6 link also erst
wenn du endgame spielst es ist aber zum level halt sehr praktisch also wenn du den wenn du
level skillung machst und gem setup vor was halt von 6 link profitiert ich kann es beim
level gar nicht benutzen zum beispiel weil es zu viel mana reservieren würde dann hätte ich
überhaupt kein mana mehr um sachen kasten zu können wenn ich 6 links balance länger macht
beim level so jetzt muss ich mal kurz akt 1 zurück und mein zeug abholen ich brauche jetzt eine
runde toxic rain toxic rain und wie ist das andere noch mal die mirage archer habe ich schon toxic
rain void manipulation ist es glaube ich bin ich ganz sicher hat er hier auch die skills drinne ich
glaube dass die kombi gewesen toxic rain ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher mirage archer support
toxic rain manipulation ach was war immer das ach ja ich sogar frostplank gekriegt lull
ja bis dann captain peng mal kurz gucken ich hatte auch eben das video ich hatte auch eben
ein video auf gerade wo ich das hergezogen habe das habe ich das habe ich auch sonst noch hier
faster attacks war es wo gab es denn faster attacks faster attacks poe gab es das auch bei nessa oder wo gab es den kram bandit quest alles klar gut dann muss
er das mal ein bisschen spielen aber da platzen sehr
best passion
zone 14 ich bin 15 optimales level hierfür eigentlich
eigentlich kann er mal sterben ob die neid
so jetzt die quest mache ich einzig und alleine nur dass ich noch eine flask kriege
glaube zumindest dass es die quest ist wo man auch noch flask kriegt
wie gesagt ich habe mir selbst für mich so ein mini guide aufgeschrieben mit ein paar
punkten drauf dass ich nicht immer beim leveln sachen vergessen aber ich glaube ich habe
so man diese sachen habe ich natürlich aufgeschrieben was das hier für eine quest war ich glaube das
ist die die die flasche vielleicht weiß einer von euch ich glaube das ist die quest wo man die
zweite flasche kriegt also kriegst du book of skill nicht die zweite flasche die man doch
hier kriegt man die zweite flasche die erste flasche habe ich schon glaube aber hier gibt
die zweite flasche sehen wir jetzt ja gleich sehen wir jetzt ja gleich zweite flasche kriegst
ganz gut kann man sogar dreimal zünden
jetzt haben wir eh wieder ordentlich mana das sagt zwar ja jetzt jetzt können wir ein bisschen
gas geben hier kann man hier durchsausen so jetzt machen wir die bandits noch ein bisschen
machen rechts die bridge ich laber nur ein bisschen laut vor mich hin weil ich muss jetzt
merken was ich machen muss ich gehe jetzt ich gehe jetzt zur brücke kill den bandit auf der
brücke dann gehe ich hoch chamber of sins macht chamber of sins geht zurück andere seite bandits
das mache ich jetzt wenn ich das richtige erinnerung habe ansonsten gucke ich in mein guide
pass mal auf nächstes jahr mache ich hier speedrun world record easy
als sie gesehen haben die die richtig guten speedrunners die halten sich kaum auf gegner
zu kühlen die haben eine richtig gute taktik wann was angeschossen wird und wann quasi
packs gekillt werden und wann nicht aber guck mal nachdem ich das geskillt habe ich jetzt
immer voll mana und voll leben das ist gut so exzellent da kann er nächstes mal schief gehen
ja da platzen sie ja die machen die speedrunner machen noch die machen die kombi aus smoke mine
smoke mein und das glaube ich spielen die also sie können so ein double double sprint jump
machen doch kollege gedreckt wo ist er denn ich sehe ihn überhaupt nicht
das ist ja nicht so als macht er jetzt wahnsinnig damage mit life leech und allem drumherum
jetzt gehen wir zum waypoint gehen eine zone zurück gehen hoch chamber of sins 28 ich komme
da freue ich mich schon drauf 28 endlich ordentliches spellslinger setup wobei so richtig
gut wird das spellslinger setup dann erst im im act drauf weil erst dann kriege ich hier
multiple projects nicht nicht projekte projektile meine ich dann wird das richtig op zum level
das ist das schnellste schnellste level setup was aktuell gibt zumindest der der der aktuelle
speedrun weltrekord hat das auch gehabt chaos spellslinger mit bisschen support noch dabei
also man macht dann drei spellslinger und das dritte ich muss gleich mal nachgucken
dreist man macht man liegt zumindest dreimal dreimal spellslinger und one shot den ganzen
bildschirm im endeffekt während man levelt später in maps natürlich mit ohne investition
nicht das brauche ich eigentlich auch nicht in das ding so jetzt muss man den boss hier
bashen wenn wir ihn finden was dann auch an pass of exile mark ist das hat so ein na das
hat so einen eigenen flow irgendwie also vor allem dann halt im endgame du kannst das stundenlang
spielen bei diablo habe ich anfälle gekriegt bei diablo 3 diablo 2 nicht das konnte ich
mir nicht lange angucken pass of exile ich kann maps zwölf stunden am stück machen
und bin danach nicht komplett brain dead brauche ich nicht habe ich schon das habe ich in
diablo 3 nicht hingekriegt übrigens totaler crap wir können es selten kriegen wir ein
bisschen das ist das schlimme an puri warum ich finde es gut ist doch top für ein game
wenn du es wenn du es lange spielen kannst ohne dass du im kopf danach komplett hinüber
bist also sowas wie zum beispiel war zone kann ich keine zwölf stunden am stück spielen
das mir viel zu anstrengend tf was denn jetzt los also was mit dem typ ach das ist in einer
bist an dem mache ich ja huge damage leute massive damage jetzt übertreiben sie es aber
hier mit ok es war gut ja da bin ich nicht equipped für jetzt ist dauernd excellent dafür
gab das richtig ex gerade irgendwas dabei was ich gleich brauche
die flaske large mana flaske meint rika das recover mehr als das rap
was sagt alter
okay instant mana
echt also ich kann ich kann pass of exile echt zehn stunden am stück spielen und bin
voll entspannt und das sage ich obwohl ich hier übelstes effekt feuerwerk bild spiele
off my main aber ich glaube das liegt auch daran pass of exile eine gute abwechslung
hat aus moment laufe ich überhaupt richtig gut ich weiß nicht aus irgendwie in game
rumgekreide allerdings immer ein bisschen unterschiedliche settings durch die maps
ab und zu mal ein bisschen traden über die seite dann ein bisschen gear checken trade
seite lurken hast du schon mal level 100 gekreint nein
das höchste war glaube ich 6 oder 97 mein ist aktuell glaub 93 oder 94 glaub 93 da muss
halt echt aufpassen dass man bei manchen doofen sachen nicht stirbt das game hat halt so
eine sache die mir damals in diablo 2 schon auf den keks gegangen ist was aber auch irgendwie
passt weil die entwickler selbst sagen dass die abloh 2 inspiration war game ist easy
as fuck und auf einmal stirbst du instant kennt wahrscheinlich ein paar easy as fuck du gehst
durch bäume bäume bäume bäume bäume alles tot und ich so hoch was war das und hast du
festgestellt ok gegnerte scheiß mods für meinen set up und ich bin da so jetzt war
mal speedrun 360 und gehen zur character selection speedrun hex deswegen würde ich
poi nie hardcore zocken das könnte ich auch nicht ja exzellent bisschen bisschen den
28 es hat so etwas wir holen jeder alles später 14 kram sellen so nix erbändet ja so ist es
vor allem manche bosse sind teilweise auch ex also gerade die metamorph sind teilweise
gar nicht zu erkennen was sie jetzt machen es ist grau in grau in grau es blubbert ein
bisschen rum und auf einmal jump das ding dann auf dich oder one shot dich mit irgendwas
also was ist eigentlich in dem chat gerade los der chat ist so hilfreich normalerweise
ist vor allem der deutsche pass auf exil chat eher eher am trollen warum ist der chat
zu hilfreich das ist das kann oder das stimmt doch irgendwas nicht welchen chat bin ich
denn hier gelandet der main chat und hilfreich was ist das für eine kombi wobei ich die
pass auf exil community finde ich nicht übel gerade der main chat ist trolling as fuck
aber kann aber das ist nicht so toxik rum schon ein bisschen aber nicht so nicht so
fakuum arm mäßig sondern die schreiben halt in den in den in den müll im endeffekt nur
rum weil das lustig finden aber ansonsten ist pass auf exil hat eine echt extrem entspannte
community es gibt natürlich auch hier ein paar scammer aber es ist ein unterschied ob
dich einer beim trade scammed oder ob einer deine mutter beleidigt weil du grad dein hilf
heil nicht getroffen hast so wie ich mein hier will ich nicht lang moment doch wetlands
aber doch ich bin doch richtig ich bin doch richtig ich muss jetzt hier den bandit bashen
aber gerade auch wenn ihr euch mal pass auf skills wenn ihr euch pass auf exil streams
anguckt da ist ganz wenig toxik bullshit dabei eigentlich heftig ja also es dürfte eines
der family freundlichsten games auf twitch sein von der community her genau genau ja
gerade deswegen es ist halt es ist halt kein pvp moin leku es ist halt kein pvp vor allem
es ist halt auch kein competitive mit ranking gedöns pvp da sind natürlich noch mehr
toxik alle was geht mit dem hier ab ob da vielleicht eine gescheite aber hier vielleicht
mal ein paar gescheite handschuhe auch sogar moment das kann ich mir immer nicht mal macht
das movement defizit
wo gehts hier rein irgendwo so hinter bandit ob das ein bisschen mehr in der mitte da ist
halt echt angenehm ich hatte jetzt in overwatch nicht so extrem gestört also jetzt beispielsweise
in overwatch weil natürlich war das teilweise schon toxic as fuck aber man man konnte es
einfach als dummes geschwätze ab tun aber es war trotzdem anstrengend weil halt gerade
overwatch auch so ein komplettes sinnes overload game ist das ist nicht das ist nicht so wie
du irgendwie jetzt keine ahnung wähl oder ein cs oder was auch immer das kannst du
acht stunden am stück spielen und es geht eigentlich aber du kannst halt kein overwatch
acht stunden am stück spielen ohne im kopf komplett im arsch zu sein weil overwatch ist
halt permanent und du kannst den overwatch auch permanent verlieren ich mein ich weiß
immer noch nicht was blizzard geritten hat dass man irgendwie keine ahnung unendlich
viel over time bekommt auch wenn das andere team dich zerrissen hat vorher und so was
keine ahnung also ich finde ich finde overwatch an vielen stellen nicht fair und von so sachen
wie 2cp reden wir erst mal gar nicht deswegen war es da doppelt abgefuckt wenn du so dumm
verloren hast zumal overwatch halt auch gerade dadurch dass es bis auf ein paar ausnahmen
an helden nicht so war dass du extrem carrying konntest slater teddy dankeschön fünf monate
exzellent subscription dankeschön war halt auch dieses team blaming immer übelst am
start das war halt auch anstrengend so jetzt muss er noch bashen die müsste hier oben
irgendwo sein wenn man klug haben peria crater life kann man nicht genug haben moment warum
geht das hat jetzt nicht so wirklich gelohnt so wo stellste lehrer rum ist eine kran man
auf flux besser 170 ja auf jeden fall moin risk dipper komplett in die falsche richtung
gelandet alle ich muss black guards machen ich muss lehrer machen man erkennt das übrigens
irgendwo ich habe letztens bei einem speedrun dude gesehen dass man anhand der positionierung
von vom waypoint kann man irgendwie erkennen wie die map aufgebaut ist endlich passe ich
dich mal ich war vorher schon on und da haben wir normale sachen gemacht und nun wollte
ich halt ein bisschen besser weg sein neuen charakterlevel unter stream chat meinte ich
kann es ja ron stream machen gesagt ich wusste dass es nicht so wahnsinnig viel interessiert
aber warum nicht paar scheint es ja doch zu interessieren und bevor ich jetzt hier alleine
vor mich hinhocke oder im stream dann ist er im stream nicht ganz so langweilig wir müssen
noch lehrer bashen wo ist er denn lehrer kommen ja würde es po e-streams gerne öfters sehen
ja die meisten glaube ich nicht mach ja auch sonst was ganz was anderes aber eine schöne
sache auf twitch ist ihr machen sie leute wirklich so wenn sie wenn sie das nicht so
sehr interessiert da gucken sie sich halt nicht an und auf youtube hast du dann die
kommentare voll mit irgendwelchen kram so nach dem motto max das ist nicht der content
für stelle max mach doch endlich wieder mal ein gutes video max früher waren deine videos
aber besser weißt du machst mal ein video was irgendwie nicht gut ankommt gleich rumgemerkt
haben das ist auf twitch nicht so auf twitch hast du viel aus malen auf twitch guckst du
dann einfach was anderes solange der ich würde auch nie auf die idee kommen leute auf ich
bin noch nicht einem sage ich jetzt einfach mal so war ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher
noch nicht einem dem ich gefollt bin bisher entfollt auf twitch ich gucke einfach nur
die sachen die mir gefallen restlass ich halt aus fertig das ist nicht wie auf youtube so
nach dem motto du wirst immer schlechter die aber
jetzt rettet noch mal mehr leute im gameplay genau
so sieht es aus aber das konnt das war ja noch das war ja noch inhaltlich die kritik ich
soll mehr leute wieder beleben in battlefield da kann ich ja verstehen dass ist ja das ja ok
da habe ich nichts dagegen aber auf youtube sind teilweise so unsinnige sachen aber es ist halt so
so das war es war zumindest lange so mittlerweile sind wir gerade auf twitch deutschland jetzt auch
nicht unbedingt auf dem wie soll man sein intellektuell aufsteigenden ast ja aber es
war lange jahre so und da bin ich auch immer bin ich immer noch davon überzeugt dass es immer
noch so ist dass auf youtube mehr low low brain leute rumlaufen als auf twitch twitch ist deutlich
big brainiger ich glaube übrigens komplett verkehrt da oben ist da oben geht es runter
twitch hat deutlich mehr brain als youtube im durchschnitt ausnahmen gibt es immer klar du
hast deppen auf twitch deppen auf youtube aber du hast auf youtube mehr es sieht man ja auch schon
ganz klar guckt euch mal wie viele dumm dumm channels es gibt gibt auf twitch auch immer mehr
gerade youtube deutschland ist irgendwie mittlerweile aber ich verfolge in youtube deutschland
eh was was gucke ich in youtube deutsch das mal kurz überlegen denn beim lost gucke ich ab und zu
mal aber auch gerade keinen modern warfare weil mich das nicht so großartig wenn spiele ich
manchmal selbst am lost gucke ich ab und zu ich gucke zelda speedruns auf deutsch mit deutschem
commentary manchmal gucke ich denn sonst noch was gucke ich sonst noch twitch deutschland
mir fällt jetzt wirklich nichts ein ich gucke ok ok ich gucke mal kurz du folgst ok du folgst
also du folgst wem folge ich wer ist wer ist hier deutschsprachig also zeig mal her
gehen wir mal hier durch sind relativ viele ok asmongold esa marathon huskers follow krabi
amon chatter 2k ist es alles nichts deutsches siegal bob ross dreamhack cs diablo 2 speedruns
der lost der lost kommt jetzt hier als nächstes mit 692 697 zuschauen der einzige deutsche
streamer den ich hatten zu gucken so und dann haben wir hier noch speedrun speedrun speedrun
ein bisschen overwatch die märchenstunde mit der oma ist am start die wusste ich noch
gesagt habe aber wie gesagt ich end follow auf twitch auch keinem speedrun speedrun speedrun
und zelda speedrun auf deutsch nee was das war ich gesagt haben ansonsten gucke ich nix
auf twitch deutschland ist ja auch nur nur müll kann man nicht sagen aber wenig wenig
dabei was mich halt interessiert fasta casting nee fasta casting brauchen wir nicht fasta
attacks fasta casting warum hat er ah warum hat er fasta casting keine fasta ah doch da
doch fasta attacks was laber ich denn alter max was laberst du für ein scheiß fasta attacks
so jetzt müssen wir mal umstocken endlich kann ich mal dieses ding verwenden was ist
jetzt besser das oder das rater nee das müll brauch ich gar nicht destroy weg destroy
alles alles selten komm wisst ihr was wie war mal mein in flare wo ist die kiste aber
mein in flare portal scrolls bald mal für was ist das noch mal gut ach das brauche
ich in act 1 act 1 muss ich auch noch meine skillbooks abholen ich kann nur so und dann
ist act 2 eigentlich auch schon fast fertig
oh nee kann das sein ich habe ich das vergessen zu machen ich glaube ich habe es nicht geöffnet
ne oh nee braucht man das ich glaube das habe ich verkackt jetzt ich glaube ich habe vergessen
das portal zu öffnen zu act 1 na zum glück ist die map noch da da rushen wir jetzt mal
schnell durch weil sonst wäre act 2 fast schon fertig gewesen ja guck da unten ich
habe vergessen aufzumachen weil ich mir gar nicht sicher bin ob man das für skillpoints
überhaupt braucht stimmt ja habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht ja skill jawoll weiß jemand
aus dem kopf was man am ende für skillpoints hat wenn man alle skillpoints macht von quests
und banditen ich glaube 24 oder bin übrigens kacken oben habe den den waypoint nicht genommen
was ich will ist weil man kann hier direkt rein laufen wieso nicht einfach portal scroll
nutzen weil ich keine portal scrolls nicht so viel portal scrolls habe und weil es schneller
geht aber wir sind auf dem weg zu spellslinger ich kann diesen feilstells hier nicht mehr
in der Mitte angucken so act 2 gleich durch
vielleicht soll ich nicht so viel chat gucken chat ich muss mal schnell was schauen mal
kurz was gucken bei twitch so leider skillen skillen skillen ok pass auf building wo muss
man jetzt lang leech live eigentlich leech ich genug live das brauche ich das machen
wir mal das ist safer das ist safer wir machen erstmal ein bisschen live leech ja live leech
das da das da und dann gehen wir hoch auf damage da kriegen wir auch ein bisschen hier
dex und und punkte und gedöns alles bis hierhin gehen wir dann gehen wir hoch den ins den
entry so mal gucken ob wir jetzt schnell durchkommen 20 ja wir sind eigentlich ganz gut glaube
man ganz gutes indikator wenn man ungefähr level von der zone ist dass man sich nicht
so lange aufgehalten hat mit sinnlos rum stehen und bashen und einfach zügig durch geht
na toll kann man den kram da unten eigentlich abschalten die quest marker nervt mich immer
ich weiß ja im prinzip wo ich lang muss ich bin gerade am überlegen den stream bei mir
normalerweise wissen ja ich habe einen 10 gigabit ubiquity switch und ich bin gerade am überlegen
ob ich den nicht verkaufen soll und mir irgendwas kleineres holen soll weil ich brauche keine
12 port 12 gigabit ich habe mir jetzt überlegt ob ich bin ich doch noch kleineren mikrotik
switch holen für irgendwie keine ahnung 150 euro und den ubiquity switch verkaufe allerdings
glaube kann ich glaube ich kann ich den nicht richtig verkaufen weil ich habe den lüfter
gemordet ja ich weiß warum warum sollte man beim switch den lüfter modden ja ich war
mir halt ein bisschen zu laut da habe ich halt andere lüfter dran gemacht so case modding
beim switch aber trotzdem eigentlich blöd weil jetzt vielleicht das ding immer los
der anderen seite ist der switch nicht schlecht der hat massig ports auch ein paar gigabit
aber halt hauptsächlich 10 g aber wo gehts denn lang da da gehts lang aber ich habe mir
halt gedacht ich verkaufe den insane speeder massive speedrun und ich kaufe dann halt
einen 2 bis 4 port 10 g von mikrotik und halt dann noch mit mit gigabit ports dran so alles
in einem aber eigentlich ist es eher nice to have und letztendlich komplett sinnlos
ab die lüfter platine von meinem server modded ja warum auch nicht das ist eigentlich eine
gute sache wir sind auch viele sachen zu laut äh da kann ich denn hier lang alter wir sind
auch viele sachen zu laut also ich habe den den server den ich die 4hkiste habe ich also
die hier die habe ich euch ja schon ein paar mal gezeigt hier jetzt gucken wir uns nicht
verdecken die habe ich ja auch soweit lüfter modded dass hier nur noch sind nur noch lüfter
drin noch 2 lüfter und noch 2 lüfter auf der cpu weil er mir sonst viel zu laut war
mit den default lüftern switch habe ich auch noch 2 lüfter reingemacht weil mir sonst
zu laut war mich und den friseur auf youtube der friseur der hat eine ganze weile auch
gestreamt macht er glaube ich irgendwelche mobile games in letzter zeit noch komm einer
sammel ein was hält denn das ding aus btf was ist das wieder für gegner mal hier
da brauchen drei stunden
jetzt erstmal den akt abschließen wie gesagt der akt ist mehr oder weniger durch das kommt
also noch der boss zack so wir skillen einmal int weil wir brauchen int das flame der schwalte
hochleveln kann i frise ja genau so heißt auf twitch aber da war jetzt in letzter zeit
nicht mal so oft on max spielt poe ja seit zwei zwei leagues wieder letzte league habe
nicht so viel gespielt account ist von 2013 und ich habe extra heute davor noch mal normal
gestreamt weil ich ja wusste jetzt einfach mal acht stunden poe anschmeißen denke ich
die meisten leute was jetzt los
hoffentlich bin ich bald 28 ich kann diesen bogen schnell zu mir nehmen angucken
die richtigen speedrunsor die haben hier noch smokemine am start und klitschen sich durch
jede öffnung durch
ja aber eigentlich das tabula ziemlich sinnvoll oder tabula wie die amis immer sagen das triggert
mich immer wenn ist das hart nein nein ich spiele keine artcore wäre das immer geil
wenn die amis sagen tabula ich sag tabula tabula eigentlich ist es aber sinnlos gerade
weil ich zum leveln maximal vierling braucht das einzig gute ist ich muss keine sockel
suchen sondern kann einfach sockel nach wie ich lustig bin
könnte es noch den account linken ach ok eigentlich gar nicht schlecht ja das das guck
ich mir mal an das guck ich mir mal an das finde ich cool aber ich wäre eh nicht zum
großen sag mal ach da ohne gehts lang hätte auch mal gleich sehen können zum krassen
poe only streamer ich mach ich mach schon mal ein zeug weiter letztendlich finde ich
es auch richtig nice auf twitch so mein jetzt ja auch also leute jetzt hier da sind die
hardcore zuschauer ich finde es halt auch auf twitch richtig nice dass ich hier überhaupt
so kram machen kann wie ich es auf twitch mache ich meine wer guckt sich denn großartig
an also auf youtube oder so wenn ich beispielsweise in reverse proxy einrichte auf einem digital
ocean server um dort irgendwelche sachen auszuprobieren das ist halt auf youtube voll für narsch
aber hier auf twitch ist halt nice und es gibt ja auch wenn man ehrlich ist wen gibt
es dann auf twitch noch der sowas macht also ich will nicht sagen dass ich der einzige
binder sowas macht ne das ist ja nie aber so viele channels in der richtung die sich
auch mal im detail mit sowas auseinandersetzen gibt es doch nicht oder wer fällt euch noch
ein ich meine es nicht hier auf twitch ich meine ich meine auf youtube auf youtube guckt
das keiner was dass hier viele leute gucken zum lernen weiß ich ist ja auch klar deswegen
mache ich ja auch deswegen erkläre ich ja auch die ein oder anderen sachen noch dabei
also aber so viele gibt es auf twitch nicht die das in der richtung machen es gibt einige
programmier streams das habe ich schon gesehen mehr als ich ursprünglich eigentlich gedacht
habe auch welche mit gar nicht so wenig zuschauer also gar nicht so wenig zuschauer was programmiert
angeht sind so keine ahnung maximal 300 ist vorbei aber die so ein bisschen linux mäßig
was machen gibt es nicht viel und ich versuche mir auch immer themen auszudenken mit denen
man was anfangen kann also zum beispiel letztens diese traffic reverse proxy geschichte mit
dockercontainer sowas das ist was das bringt vielen leuten daheim was die zum beispiel
ihre nextcloud von außen zugreifbar machen wollen und sowas und ich sage dann auch immer
noch ein paar takte dabei also ich sage immer noch dabei leute ich würde es euch nicht
empfehlen einfach so auch wenn es damit geht ich würde es euch nicht empfehlen die sache
einfach so ins internet zu stellen weil halt wenn authentifizierung probleme hat dann jeder
kann sich eure nextcloud sachen angucken ich versuche dann auch immer noch ein bisschen
drumherum zu erzählen so nach dem motto ja was würde ich stattdessen machen stattdessen
würde ich wenn es geht einen vpn benutzen wenn ich schon von außen zugreifbar machen
würde und sowas also ich versuche hier schon die sachen auch so zu machen dass die leute
was von haben aber trotzdem gibt es finde ich nicht so viel auf twitch in der richtung
und für mich ist halt nice weil ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich mal mit so technik kram
und es ist ja man muss mal ehrlich sagen jetzt mal leute true 0w man muss ja mir ehrlich
sagen was wir hier für technik sachen im stream machen ist schon ein bisschen advanced
also das hat nichts mit zu tun wie keine ahnung wie klicke ich mir unter windows gescherten
ordner an oder sowas ja also das ist schon teilweise relativ advanced muss man sagen
und das ist das ist so advanced dass da auch leute die in dem bereich arbeiten sich durchaus
erst mal einlesen müssen und das nicht einfach mal so nebenbei aus dem erbel schütteln ja
und das gibt es ja so gar nicht und das finde ich halt cool dass man auch so advanced sachen
machen kann und ich hätte nie gedacht dass mir da so viele leute bei zugucken wir haben
teilweise haben wir gut jetzt mal bei dem apple events außen vor mit 700 zuschauer
0 aber im durchschnitt wenn man was halbwegs interessantes technisches macht auch was
was durchaus anspruchsvoll ist haben wir 200 zuschauer 150 150 bis 250 schwankt und auch
sonntags wo wir ein prinzip einfach nur sinnlose reaction sinnlose reaction content machen
ja haben auch teilweise manchmal manchmal sogar bis 300 wo ich immer denke da fuck und
das alles und da bin ich auch ganz froh und ich habe ja nie großartig werbung gemacht
auf youtube auch und was ich cool finde dass ja auch mittlerweile viele da sind die gar
nicht über youtube gekommen sind sondern einfach so gefunden haben das ist echt nice
dank mir hast du den serverraum zu hause war das cool was hast du für den server drinstehen oder
was hast du für geräte drinstehen im serverraum muss ja nicht zwangsläufig ein server stehen
kacke nur boss alter olo olo olo olo boss boss kannst du mal sterben
dies excellent auf wisst ihr was mir gerade auffällt ich spiele die ganze zeit ohne köcher
ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen aber frauen wir nicht overrated so akt 3 das und jetzt gehen
wir hoch auf direkt end würde ich sagen hier rum gehen wir etwas unoptimiertes bild egal
ich respekt da eben was später in vier in vier level spiele ich spells länger das halte ich
jetzt auch noch aus weiß ich nicht ob der tod genervt ist keine ahnung mach mal plat eine
stunde 48 geht das für anfangen 3 ich weiß dass das speed run mäßig übelst müll ist ist mir klar
aber so rein aus noob casual sicht wie gesagt in doppelter zeit war war tie tie killer 330
den akt 10 durch auf klarissa steh auf kogas dankeschön acht monate
so drei level noch excellent drei level noch da kann ich endlich spells länger umrüsten
von der seite bin ich ja schon lange nicht mehr reingelaufen oder kommt mir nicht man
kommt immer rein in die seite rein von akt 2 so slums wir gehen erst gar nicht in die stadt
runter so crematorium müssen wir jetzt wenn ich das richtige erinnerung habe wie gesagt
81234 kann ich halbwegs auswendig crematorium müssen wir einzige sache wo ich immer noch
ein bisschen drauf achten muss ist dass ich alle skill quests mache das heißt da muss ich dann
zwischendurch mal gucken das keine skill quest übersehen ach ja und harvest sammel ich nicht
auf weil die low seats bringen nix
unker
die paar extra ganze mit passiv nachschauen ja stimmt so wo ist das crematorium das geht
meistens über solche prücken drüber und dann ist es am ende der map irgendwo
hier das ist immer irgendwo am ende der map nachdem aber so ein paar prücken gerannt ist
da ist es doch so wenn ich jetzt hier richtig in erinnerung habe muss ich gar nicht richtig
sicher ob ich den stockwerk runter muss oder ob ich direkt ob der boss hier direkt ist ob
der ist direkt ja massiv speedrun oder kaputt wie ich die bringen immer dick xp aber das
mana liege und life liege das hat sich schon ausgezahlt gemacht zu specken bin ich deutlich
weniger fragil als am anfang
ich gucke dann ob ich paar skill quests übersehen habe aber
das ist doch nicht die trial die brauche ich nicht die habe ich schon
hier sind wir ach jetzt kommt der kram einmal piety bastion loop boss ja ich habe lightning
resist da machst du nix da piss dich alde die hat nicht mit resist gerechnet da kann
man die eigentlich killen oder das ist das ist cryptet egal wie viel damage man macht
das ist garantiert scripted man kann die nicht killen sonst würden die ganzen speed
runner die hier killen und irgendwie den dritten akt überspringen ne ne das geht bestimmt
nicht bleibt immer bei ein hp stehen feels a batman das gute ist halt wenn man schnell
ist dann haben sich die maps noch nicht gesettelt und man findet die sachen einfacher so ok
was muss ich als nächstes machen ich muss jetzt diese diese statuen einsammeln
einsammeln drei stück und dann raus marketplace
gleich haben wir es glaube ich bin falsch eine eine statue ist es sind immer zwei statuen
glaube vor dem waypoint und einen nach dem waypoint habe ich mal in einem guide gelesen
oder auch nicht dann war es eine davon immer zwei danach dann war es umgedreht dann war
es umgedreht das auf jeden fall immer gleich sofern der guide stimmt den immer da vor
der weile angeguckt habe dann ist es immer eine statue vor dem waypoint und immer zwei
nach dem waypoint was übrigens auch noch eine sache die mir echt gut an pacifixer
gefällt dadurch dass das game so wir es an vielen stellen ich meine das ist ja an vielen
stellen echt null intuitiv bringt halt so gewisses game knowledge voll was aber ich
kann es verstehen dass sie das mit pacifixer 2 ein bisschen zugänglicher machen wollen
ja du hast ja ich glaube in pacifixer 2 kriegen die leute ja dann beispielsweise auch 6 links
auf billig items zum besseren einstieg und so wobei später wird sie eh noch selbst linken
lassen es ist es ist also pacifixer ist schon sehr viel so so mystisch irgendwie du weißt
nicht genau was passiert aber es gibt dann irgendwelche guides und irgendwelche sachen
leute die was data meint haben und dann irgendwie eine app oder eine website erstellt haben
die die wahrscheinlichkeit ausrechnet für irgendwas also da ist schon sehr viel magic
bei pacifixer dabei so leute zwei level noch zwei level dann haben wir den bogen stells
hinter uns aber so wirklich so wirklich gut geht es erst im nächsten akt dann mit crater
wie heißt das ding auf deutsch größere projektile keine ahnung multiple projectiles crater multiple
projectiles größere mehrere größere projektile als exzellent ich weiß schon warum ich so
dinger nie auf deutsch spiele bei the way wir haben uns noch letztens die xbox präsentation
war auf dem pc man hat irgendwie gedacht sie wäre auf der xbox aber jebaited die halo demo
war auf dem pc war aber auch irgendwo klar hätte mich gewundert wenn sie da nicht irgendwie
bisschen getrickst hätten skill points in catacombs nicht vergessen was in catacombs
gibt es skill points in catacombs gibt es respects oder in catacombs gibt es in lab
und respect ja irgendwie so genau die lab habe ich schon genau ich muss jetzt battlefront
oder warfront oder wie das heißt raus die guards killen und dann solaris den typ bashen
wir noch mal schnell der macht mit zu viel damage und tropf nix weil ich auch überhaupt
keine props tropfs brauche nein ich will warfront raus irgendwo wenn wir glück haben hier was
habe ich nicht genug int oder sage ich bin nicht big brain genug um flamendash zu lernen
das glaube ich aber net ja da brauchen wir noch einen weiteren point und ich habe mich
übrigens voll verskillt muss sie gar nicht hin sondern muss dahin der hier ist verskillt
aber ich werde es überleben kann er einfach später rückgänge machen oder ich meine
im prinzip ich speck eh komplett um wenn ich 70 bin oder 75 oder vielleicht mit 80 vielleicht
speck ich mit 80 erst um speck mit 80 komplett um wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich brauche
ich aber ich brauche bestimmt 30 respect points oder so weil von dem tree auf karst
und krit dings ich sage immer ich sage immer frost nova weil diablo aber es ist eis nova
ganz anderer skill tree aber besser angenehm leveln anstatt sich darum zu quälen dann
gebe ich lieber ein bisschen was aus für skill points jepp cock genau was jetzt noch gut
wäre bei dem spiel wenn die es schaffen würden dass mehr leute am start bleiben ich meine
die haben ins kann lass mich hier hochspringen geben ich meine die haben mehr spieler als
je zuvor im endeffekt durch die ganzen leaks aber die leaks dass die mal die meisten leute
machen es halt wie ich die spiel eins zwei monate oder die spielen so bis zur hälfte
der leak hälfte zwei drittel der leak und dann haben sie keinen bock mehr es wäre cool
wenn sie noch irgendwie paar mechanik einbauen würden dass die leute auch dran bleiben was
halt blöd ist wenn du dann atlas halbwegs fertig hast und und eins bis fünf gute chance
hast was willst du großartig machen gibt sicherlich noch ein paar möglichkeiten da was da irgendwas
zu drehen zum beispiel was ich mir überlegt habe was was ich was ich eigentlich für eine
richtig geile geile idee halte die leute leveln ja massig charaktere in so einer leak also
wenn man sich manche streamer anguckt und manche leute haben irgendwie gefühlt irgendwie
10 15 charaktere am ende oder so und man könnte so machen dass man ich weiß kann sein dass
es kompletter schwachsinn ist aber klingt klingt für mich erst erst mal ganz nice dass
man quasi so und so und so dass es irgendwie so ein extra punktesystem gibt wo man sich
dann halt irgendwelche sachen für craften gieren was auch immer kann also es ist egal
was man damit macht wo man quasi sagen man einen 80 plus charakter opfern kann und dafür
kriegt man dann irgendwelche currency items oder so mit denen man was machen kann dann
hat es nämlich auch sinn einfach charaktere zu leveln und wenn man sie nicht mehr spielen
will kann man sie einfach opfern für currency für es müsste aber irgendwas spezielles
sein also jetzt keine keine normale currency irgendwas eigenes paradies für botter ist
auch egal ist das spiel eh schon prein fließ abonniert wird beim dankeschön excellent
subscription massif ja big moment ich muss ihn erstmal kippen ja big prein subscription
dankeschön extrem sinnvolle tür 8 stunden chillstab playlist morpheus ich kann dir gar
nicht sagen was es ist erst beste playlist genau wo geht es runter da geht es runter
excellent so danach machen wir docks und wenn man docks fertig haben rösten auf spellslinger
um perfekt so werden wir es machen weil ich merke schon dass dieser feilstell sind immer
lange gut geht mal überlegen was wir dann für spellslinger brauchen aber wir müssten
eigentlich alles da haben essence train haben wir glaube mitgenommen von irgendeiner quest
oder können es kaufen contagions haben wir solrent haben wir glaube auch spellslinger
kann man kaufen in act 3 also wir müssten mehr oder weniger alles haben wenn nicht muss
noch ein paar gems kaufen es könnte sein dass ich die library quest noch machen muss je
nachdem was ich brauche da überhaupt keinen bock drauf habe ehrlich gesagt welche liebmechanik
ist seine liebste naja wie gesagt ich den account gibt zwar seit 2013 aber so richtig
angefangen habe ich erst mit metamorph wieder also ich kann zu den ganzen leakmechaniken
nicht viel sagen also ich meine ich kenne sie halt die übrig gebliebenen die hier drinnen
sind also preach finde ich ultra nice einfach weil ich auf monster bashen stehen wann ist
eigentlich der c++ stream also preach fand ich sehr finde ich sehr nice und ich finde
die aktuelle auch cool nämlich aus einem grund ich mag das craft überhaupt nicht ich
beschliebe irgendwelche monsters aber es gibt mehr high end items und man kann die seeds
einfach verkaufen bald das andere mal und durch durch die seeds zahlen kann man halt
massif kohle machen delve bin ich noch nie so richtig reingekommen
delft bin ich noch nie so richtig reinkommen ich habe immer mal ein paar level gemacht
ja cobalt stream den cobalt stream machen wir bald ich habe mich ja schon darauf eingestellt
dass ich hier mal wieder cobalt stream muss aber mal wieder was heißt mal wieder ich
habe die ko dass ich jetzt demnächst endlich mal cobalt stream muss darum das wird aber
ätzend also es gibt kaum was schlimmeres als cobalt zu streamen also cobalt zu programmieren
und den kram auch noch streamen zu müssen ist ja wirklich fast schon folter also wenn
die noch irgendwelche ich fungier da gerne als berater wenn die noch irgendwelche foltermethoden
suchen wo man es den leuten danach nicht ansieht dass sie gefoltert wurden dann sollte man
mit cobalt probieren da kannst du waterboarding und alles mögliche einpacken einfach fünf
stunden ko bollen der erzählt dir alles sterben blies sterben blieb mop mop
da kann ich mich noch in der beta dran erinnern in der beta war es ja auch so dass das spiel
drei schwierigkeitsgrade hatte was jetzt ja nicht mehr so ist jetzt ist ja eine durchgängige
kampagne du hattest ja quasi nur die ersten drei acts und halt dann wie in diablo quasi
normal cruel merciless was glaube ich in poe und in docks hat man sich damals level geboostet
as fuck du bist einfach durch den kompletten act gerannt nur im docks zu gehen und power
zu leveln da kann ich das ding jetzt mal finden wenn ich das hier durch hab kommt spellslinger
set up ran dann kann ich dieser bogen müll weg war was das es kommt da angewirbelte
schalte aber unten ist es pass auf jetzt ist fair graves
pass auf jetzt ist fair graves nein ist das richtige sehr gut jawoll
kommen wir nehmen mal nach portal scroll so lunaris 2 abgeben und dann neue gems
ja so ich wollte die gems jetzt wird es auch noch kurz tun vielleicht warte ich doch bis
31 da kann ich mehr gems reinpacken ja ich warte bis 31 bis 31 ist besser ich warte bis
31 da kann ich noch mehr gems rein machen ist ja schnell gelevelt hier kommen wir sind
jetzt quasi schon 29 dauert fünf minuten sie ist in einem durch ich würde gerne aber
dafür habe ich zu spät angefangen zu streamen ich würde es gerne am stück machen dass ich
hinter mir hab aber es wird glaube ich zu lang da müsste ich bis er nacht um vier oder
so stream auf gehts der des kacke an dem fahrer ich immer
an dem du verreck ich immer aneis das geht ja durch sein energie schild ok vielleicht
verrecke ich doch nicht der kann ja gar nix außer diese komischen feuerbälle
verrecken please easy af um nicht zu sagen ja 29 zwei level warten wir noch da kann ich
mir gems equippen du bist dabei muss selber klein aber mal gucken wie lange ich mach also
den act machen auf jeden fall noch fertig und ich würde ja auch gerne ak den nächsten
act noch machen mal gucken mal gucken wie lang vielleicht vielleicht mal auch komplett
morgen auf stimmt nee wenn ich morgen aufwacht stream machen will dann kann ich nicht bis
er nacht um vier spielen soll das gehen als auch wieder wahnsinnig sinnvolle tür ja
aber kann das sein dass der lunares dass der lunares temple stufe eins immer das gleiche
layout hat mir kommt das so bekannt vor
es sieht immer gleich aus irgendwie oder es gibt nur zwei layouts kann auch sein ne ok
das letzte mal ging es glaube ich links lang und jetzt nicht ne dann siehts bloß so aus
ne ne dann siehts echt nur so aus dann gibt es doch mehr layouts was gilt jetzt eigentlich
hier habe ich mich verskillt jetzt kommt das da kommt die chaos notes ein respect brauche
ich noch aber kriege ich später in den nächsten in den späteren akten gibt es ja respect und
das soll ich in einer quest oh ne ne dich lass ich da einfach mal stehen in der kampagne
hat doch alles das gleiche layout nee das spiel ist komplett randomized jeder durchgang
oder was heißt jeder durchgang jedes jedes map betreten nach zehn minuten ist randomized
bis auf ganz wenige ausnahmen manche maps sind gleich ich glaube das badehaus ist immer
gleich und paar andere sachen aber 90 prozent des spiels ist komplett randomized
oh ich fürchte wir müssen piety noch killen mit mit diesem komischen bogen setup
und das ist eines der nervigsten gebiete im ganzen spiel da gibt es nämlich diese komischen
genau die hier die sind ultra nervig und machen damage as fuck komischen weiß nicht was das
ist da tentakel monster aber dann nur minimal nee die maps sind teilweise komplett unterschiedlich
wie gesagt das letzte mal ging es bei mir hier in lunaris 2 nach oben weiter anstatt
nach unten alter die tentakel monster hier werden sie baro mal hier dem wird das gefallen
kappa hd
ja das ja das stimmt das cipher dark da blick ich aber auch nicht zu 100 prozentig durch
ich hab das oh nee hier gehts gar nicht weiter ich hab das jetzt in ein paar speedruns gesehen
die erkennen extrem also wirklich extrem gut wo ich mich frage wie kriegen sie das hin
wie die maps verlaufen wie gesagt manchmal spawnt irgendwas schräg und daran erkennt
das sofort hier gehts weiter und so was also richtig da brauchst du richtig krass game knowledge
lunaris aus akt 7 lunaris aus akt 7 hat doch gar keine sei nicht alles im ersten stockwerk
ist ja gut hier tentakel fiecher ist ja mal gut aber auch damage
welches back-end framework würdest du empfehlen bin noch in der ausbildung und programmiere
hauptsächlich mit c++ cute back-end framework für web oder vermute ich jetzt mal also für
was sonst ja aber c++ kann ich dir da leider nichts gutes zu raten ich bin ja absolut kein
c++ fan also ich könnte den ganzen tag im stream machen wo ich c++ flame cute ist eines
der wenigen guten sachen aus der c++ welt leider ist es c++ aber in c++ kann ich dir
wirklich kein gutes kenne ich mich nicht aus außerdem würde ich anfälle kriegen wenn
ich noch mehr c++ machen müsste als notwendige oder darf es auch was anderes als für c++
sein dann kann ich dir mehr raten aber den back-end framework für c++ kann ich dir leider
nichts zu sagen ich bin noch nie auf die idee gekommen eine web anwendung mit c++ back-end
zu machen mich ich hoffe die idee braucht auch noch eine weile bis ich da draufkomme
moment hier war ich schon warum laufe ich denn wieder zurück also wenn du wenn anderes
also wenn es was anderes als c++ sein darf dann sehr viele möglichkeiten also meine
persönliche lieblings kombination ist ja dotnet core c-sharp entity framework asp.net core
also im prinzip asp.net core mit c-sharp und java script vue js frontend das ist so meine
lieblings kombi auch finde ich auch sehr einsteiger freundlich asp.net ist eigentlich ganz nett
auch gibt es auch sehr viele tutorials zur gtk moment es geht um web es geht um web back-end
frameworks für web backends da ist gtk jetzt nur wirklich nett das richtige für
ich glaube wir sind hier gleich durch ein ein level noch die mal die bashing noch die
fiecher hier bin ich 31 und jetzt gibt es hier nichts mehr oder was ich wollte es auch
bis 31 mann train ist nope ich bin ja selbst da nicht der große pro was das angeht na
ich bin auch am lernen aber vielleicht haben wir welche im chat die sich gut auskennen
also ich will einfach nur 31 noch da vielleicht mit den fiechern hier möchte ich mich nicht
verspielen du kannst ja respekten klar es kostet ein bisschen was aber du kannst ja
respekten also ich werde es hier auch machen ich level hier mit diesem mit diesem bogen
stellst jetzt bis 31 dann switch ich auf chaos spelslinger und dann respekte ich quasi so
ab 75 oder 70 respekte ich noch mal komplett auf gas und kreat eisenhofer das kostet wahrscheinlich
schon so 30 respect points oder sowas aber du bekommst 18 respect points in der kampagne
oder ich gut ich meine ich weiß vielleicht erzähle ich dir jetzt ja auch zeugt was was
du schon alles weißt ja kann ja auch sein ich glaube du kriegst 18 respect points in
der kampagne what the fuck kannst du mal verpissen ja oh nee oh das ding macht damage und die
respect ops sind jetzt auch nicht so teuer zumal manche skill skill einfach viel angenehmer
sind zum leveln sterben please ja das macht mir kein damage palti da kannst du mal was
du willst wo ist er hin ach da lull das macht mir kein damage palti das einzige was mir
damage macht sind die mehlerangriffe und diese komischen pfeile da
damit kannst du mir nicht schocken hier diesmal ist aber echt nett die macht ja nur dieses
mehler ding lull okay jetzt ist dauerung das war aber doch noch knapp ja so und wir sehen
mal 31 na super so dann machen wir jetzt noch ein 0,1 level und dann specken wir um irgendwo
ist vollkommen egal ok bis level 31 ok das stimmt schon einfach drauf los specken ist
im pass auf extra nicht so sinnvoll hast du pass auf building installiert trainers also
pass auf building ist das ist dieses tool hier ja wo man sich skills builds angucken
kann ok excellent so also was brauchen wir denn jetzt für skills so also wir brauchen
spell slinger brauchen wir erstmal dreimal spell slinger ne war der nicht quatsch erstmal
den ganzen krab abholen so haben wir hier irgendwas so noch brauchen das kann man gebrauchen
all das müll brauchen wir alles nicht ok dann muss ich den ganzen kram mal in meiner
kiste ordnen also wir brauchen jetzt wir brauchen soul rent wir brauchen also den ganzen müll
kann ich schon mal wegschmeißen das kommt jetzt fort das brauchen wir jetzt nichts davon
brauchen wir außer flame dash flame dash behalten wir noch so wir brauchen spell slinger
haben wir auch schon mal ne moment das sind das ist ja das sind die anderen gems von meinem
müll von meinem letzten char also wir brauchen ok flame dash soul rent wir brauchen dreimal
spell slinger spell slinger dreimal spell slinger brava irgendwie sieht das fast gleich
aus ne achso ja wenn das nur endgame zeigt dann schwierig ja aber auf der anderen seite
durch die kampagne kommst du eigentlich fast immer irgendwie durch in der kampagne ist
eigentlich das einzige worauf man achten muss dass man genug resis hat wenn man genug resis
hat ist alles gut ok spell slinger soul rent spell slinger spell slinger dann brauchen
wir hier noch con tajen bisschen auseinander rücken tajen essence train spell slinger
con tajen spell slinger soul rent gut das brauchen wir oh ich brauche noch ne wand
vom weg aber hier noch dash ich brauch eine wand wer verkauft mir stäbe
wer von den verkauften ihr zeugs irgendeine wand mit vier socken kann nicht so schwierig
sein mit drei socken ja irgendwie sowas da
perfekt ane hier guck mal den den immer gut perfekt zack weg damit links einmal linken
was komm ja weg damit
so das da kommt jetzt rein jetzt muss ich gucken da ich kein mist skille keine mist
gems ausrüsten da kommt rein spell slinger mal kurz nachgucken skills also essence train
spell slinger gut das kriege ich erst später und das kriege ich auch erst später das kriege
ich auch erst später frenzy frenzy brauche ich genau increased area kriege ich glaub
auch später war kriegt man increased area ach das ist 38 ok das kenne ich auch später
dann lassen wir das dann lassen wir increased area erst mal ok curse und hit kriege ich
auch noch nicht das ist auch später faster attacks ok also frenzy und faster attacks
brauchen wir jetzt wo gibt es frenzy wo kann frenzy kaufen frenzy gibt es in akt 2
1 kreenex ok hier brauchen wir frenzy zack und controlled
controlled destruction ich glaube wir brauchen mal 2 vielleicht ganz sicher faster attacks
faster attacks frenzy so controlled destruction ich glaube jetzt habe ich alles ich glaube
jetzt habe ich alles also wir brauchen der rest ist 38 frenzy haben wir hier fasted curse
und hit gibt es erst später essence train controlled destruction ok machen wir das
mal hier controlled destruction essence train spell slinger und dann haben wir spell slinger
control rent haben wir auch noch nicht creator multiple projectiles haben wir auch erst später
efficiency wo gibt es ein efficiency wo gibt es das library quests ok es geht mal fort
gut ja sind wir fertig sind wir erst mal equipped wenn ich jetzt nix vergessen habe soul train
haben wir uns doppel checken hier essence train soren spell slinger haben wir im chest frenzy
und fast attacks haben wir in den schoen drin contagion spell slinger haben wir in der chest
ja passt doch alles gut ok dann gucken wir mal ob das was taugt jetzt ich habe keinen
bock die library quests zu machen wo ist denn die library eigentlich die ist garden glaube
ich da kommen wir jetzt direkt vorbei vielleicht vielleicht war das doch schnell ja das könnte
ich machen das könnte ich machen die gems kaufen aber stimmt eigentlich egal hast recht
könnte ich machen aber ich wollte eigentlich erstmal gucken dass ich quasi wie ich zurecht
kommen würde wenn es jetzt eine neue league wäre aber es bescheuert ich meine ich laufe
mit mit einem tabula rasa irgendwie gold rim und irgendwie movement speed boots rum also
hat es damit eh nix zu tun da kann ich dir auch gleich kaufen gehen da hast du eigentlich
recht ok f fisch ist oder wie heißt das f fisch ist die support so dann brauchen wir
noch was und troll destruction haben wir aber mit der fisch ist die brauchen wir zweimal
aber es auch keine komische library quest man oh cry next das ist bitter curse und hit
despair despair haben wir aber noch curse und hit purse und hit purse und hit was habe
ich mir eben gelöscht ich kann knob die kram irgendwie rückgängig machen don't save building
das ist cast on grid irgendwie was das ist was anderes level wo habe ich das noch mal
her gehabt hier das bild zum level so und jetzt import von paste bin zack so also was
habe ich ja fürs gills vorhin gelöscht curse und hit fast attacks increased area aha creased
area gott jetzt haben wir alles na jetzt haben alles jop ah crater multiple projectiles brauchen
excellent crater jawoll kommen zweimal ich weiß nicht ob wir es nicht zweimal brauchen
haben wir alles meine andere kram ist zwar 38 aber das macht nichts dann habe ich es
wenigstens schon dann habe ich wenigstens schon und mal kass habe ich 1 zu wenig kann
das sein wo soll das noch rein bei essence train da muss noch ok ich brauche noch ein
feeling ich habe irgendwo noch was ich habe hier meine super aufgeräumten kiste garantiert
ach nee ich bin doch doof guck mal wir können es doch ganz anders machen ich kann das doch
einfach das da rein machen nee moment ich bin verwirrt weltslinger solent justy das
da ja exe ah verwirrung pur so irgendein schild könnten wir jetzt noch gleich suchen
aber passt ok zack zack frenzy auf rechts klick das weg und auf weh ach nee wo ist
mein flamendash flamendash flamendash plantation kommt cool ok wir haben es geschafft hoch
schwere geburt oh Mist jetzt muss ich da noch mal raus laufen weil ich den waypoint nicht
habe aber 3200 fusions ist hart so ok gucken wir mal ob wir jetzt schon wenigstens was
killen ok wir müssen irgendwie wieder wir müssen den ausgang finden ja fällt doch
etwas schneller um wo ist der ausgang lasst mich raus lasst mich raus hab den waypoint
nicht genommen ja die fallen doch etwas schneller um jetzt sind unic items immer erst nein eher
umgedreht in der regel sind rares besser es gibt ein paar ausnahmen da sind uniks quasi
erforderlich dass ein bild funktioniert zum beispiel wenn du law life spielen willst gibt
es dings wie heißt chevrons wrappings oder so ähnlich brauchste oder auch wenn du sachen
willst wo die gegner explodieren mit schock dann brauchst du impulser gibt andere rare
varianten ja aber manche sachen gehen nur mit unix aber in der regel ist sind rares
besser jetzt verkommen wie schnell die umfallen und ich habe noch nicht mal ansatzweise hier
nicht mal ansatzweise gutes gier noch nicht mal alle alle gems drinnen lasst mich raus
ich will doch nur den ausgang finden da jetzt raus also es gibt genug leute ich würde sogar
mal sagen die die meisten der quasi so high end gier spieler die haben so gut wie keine
du ich will nicht sagen gar keine aber so gut wie keine unix drinnen in ihrem end game
gier ja herr tanter ok was macht der dude wieder da der war doch schon dauern ich bin
jetzt richtig dumm ich habe warum habe ich den waypoint hier nicht genommen dass eigentlich
mega hängen geblieben der waypoint ist der offensichtlichste von allen ich habe hier
nicht gekrappt weil hier oben geht es jetzt weiter
boah die fallen jetzt aber schon ganz gut um die geht schon was weil ich mir auch nicht
sicher bin ob nicht wenn du wirklich gutes end game setup an also an bild und items hast
ob du nicht lieber in anderen bild aus als headhunter spielst keine ahnung also gibt
bestimmt builds da ist das nicht so der wahnsinn was anderes besser zumal die meisten leute
nie in ihrer league und an headhunter kommen werden
ich habe letztens einen clip gesehen von einem der war irgendwie halb afk auf einer map und
geht dann mit der mauszeiger über den item und stellt fest headhunter getroppt nimmt
es halt ohne irgendwie die mine zu verziehen zur kenntnis so headhunter
ich muss den kram guck mal die das sind alles level eins gems gewesen die die dinger fallen
um wir nix euch hasse diese dinger die sprengen immer in die luft physical damage stacheln
hier muss jetzt der waypoint klar kommen ey please verrecken
we will be best friends beast
die bete mich doch nicht immer so mep kein schiebe jetzt schon wieder gebetet hier ist
das lab hier will ich gar nicht hin
ich glaube die map ist nicht random meist oder wenig random meist
glaube ich hätte rechts laufen müssen hier immer über die hauptstraße trotz den ich
es gibt ja so ein paar sachen die in die den einen bandit an der brücke findet man
auch immer über die straße so man stehen geblieben man stehen geblieben
wir können uns hier wir holen uns hier unten noch dach nächstes mal mal später
live kann man nicht genug haben
übrigens ein respect brauche ich da noch genau nämlich den da habe ich verskillt übrigens
wenn man control gedrückt hält kann man instance backen guckt hier so ohne bestätigen zu müssen
waren die ganzen ultra speed runner dudes und was auch noch geiler trick ist was ich
von irgendeinem speedrun mensch abgeguckt habe was ich nicht brauche aber was cool ist
man kann wenn der hier tot ist man kann movement auf sterben please so leute ich will euch
ja nur was zeigen geht mal fort also was man machen kann man kann lehrtaste man kann lehrtaste
auf skill skill use den da legen und dann kann man movement darauf legen und dann kann
man quasi mit der lehrtaste laufen während man in den menus rumklickt
also ich klicke jetzt nicht also ich bin jetzt hier im inf und klicke rum und mit der lehrtaste
kann man laufen ich bin im inf und wenn ich jetzt hier ist doof aber im inventar und mit
lehrtaste kann man auch zum speedrun mensch abgeguckt weil die die die switchen immer
ihre gems während sie quasi mit lehrtaste laufen das gehr das geht im tree wenn du
den tree aufhast geht guckt also wenn du weißt wo du hin laufen muss kannst du skillen skillen
und laufen dabei was man kann mit num skills nutzen ohne sie zu drücken und das legal
hä wie verstehe nicht was meinste wie ohne sie num musste doch auch drücken so ich will
jetzt noch schnell durch den akt hier durch sonst wird das mit morgen morgen früh aufwacht
stream nix hier volle pulle speedrun mode aber das geht deutlich angenehmer als diese
komische bogenstells geschichte vorher was setzt skill auf ein ziffern block und während
der an ist einfach num ausmachen während da geht das skill weiter ohne dass was drückt
ach so autocast quasi
das meine ich so in passive excel also game knowledge ist richtig huge wenn man sich da
auskennt autocast
übrigens bei dem boss verreck ich immer weil ich nicht weiß was ich machen muss wenn
das ein a e macht ansonsten ist der boss easy
ich habe aber übelst krasses rng glück oder wie ich hierdurchkommen grad
mappack
omega lull
übrigens mal ne frage an euch chat wenn ihr ins bett geht schlafen
habt ihr dann irgendwas laufen im hintergrund oder habt ihr am liebsten toten stille so
und stille
podcast okay
manchmal youtube wernst ja ja gut wenn schon youtube damit youtube wernst wenns android
ist stille ja ich bei mir ist mittlerweile anders also früher konnte es mir nicht leise
genug sein aber irgendwie seit ein paar jahren so drei vier jahren und nicht ganz aber zwei
drei jahren hab ich angefangen irgendwelche streams zu gucken auf dem smartphone auf twitch
da hab ich mich jetzt so dran gewöhnt dass ich gar nicht mehr richtig pennen kann wenn
nix läuft ist eigentlich schlecht weil ich denke man schläft schlechter wenn was läuft
insgesamt aber ich hab mich da so dran gewöhnt ich kann es da kaum kaum pennen ohne deswegen
mache ichs jetzt so deswegen freue ich mich immer wenn irgendwelche speedrun marathons
laufen ja und gerade läuft ja auch hier das ding twitch twitch ja aktuell läuft ja der
kram gerade das kann man sich immer richtig gut im hintergrund geben wann ist gamestown
quick gucken immer die sind mir zu politisch korrekt mittlerweile und weil bei solchen
speedrun events da reißen sich die leute immer ein bisschen im raum und schreien nicht
auf einmal random rum wenn du dir manche streams anguckst da musst du angst haben dass du dich
gleich das todes erschreckst weil irgendein typ gerade ausflippt und so speedrun marathons
guck hier mal gerne gut boss killer ist das ist das ding hier natürlich nicht ne aber
für den kram hier reichts so und vielleicht kennt sich irgendjemand von euch mit dem boss
aus also bei dominus check ich nie wie ichs überlebe wenn der sein regen ae macht äh
wo ist der gegner ach da der macht irgendwann so ein so so so ein blut blut regen ae und
ich weiß nicht wie ich da ausweiche wenn du in der plase bist macht er welche plase
wow jetzt hab ich auf den chat geguckt ey ist ja gut komisches fisch da geh weg btw
ich mag die musik in dem temple nicht ah rein in die glocke ok what the fuck ist denn jetzt
geht grad los mal verrecken please so ups die attacke kenne ich da bin schonmal dran verreckt
aber ich hab nicht aufgepasst deswegen spiel ich übrigens softcore da kannst du auch mal
sowas verkacken gut ich hab resis da passieren eigentlich sind die meisten storybosse übelst
easy as fuck so ich muss jetzt mal gucken was ihr meint mit plase mit plase in die ich
rein muss bei dem ae also ich mein gerade ist ja nix da in welche plase muss ich rein
jetzt dominos erstmal platt jetzt respawn da sobald aber in welche plase denn ich muss
im mehler range ok ja mach deine komische animation
jetzt hier ja das ist ja einfach wenn was weiß ich renne immer vor allem weg was was
an bossen glänzt und glüht weil die meistens damage machen wenn irgendwas glänzt und
glüht ok das ist einfach wenn was weiß um nicht zu sagen easy as fuck
einfach fest hängen aber der macht mir zu viel damage oder der kriegste doch kriegste
doch gar nicht geheilt echt ok akua oh ach nee
oh gar nicht so schlecht aha ok ach stimmt die hab ich ja ganz vergessen
so ich muss noch mal kurz zurück gucken ob ich alle skillbücher abgeholt hab
wie sein dass ich irgendwas vergessen hab
wann ist denn so der beste zeitpunkt das normale lab zu machen nach dem nächsten act
oder bei diesem act ich hab alles abgeholt macht ihr zocken noch spaß ja es fehlt einem
das richtige das ist das problem das war eines der besten sachen die ich machen konnte
dass ich wieder hier grind game wie pass auf exile angefangen hab
glaube ich mach das lab jetzt ich geh in die status lab mach ich noch
ich glaube ich glaube ich warte bis 38 weil 38 habe ich dann alle spells die ich brauche
wenn wir doch jetzt schon blatt aqueduct sind wir mal durch eigentlich brauche ich das
überhaupt nicht killen wozu nee der boss ist wahrscheinlich echt kein problem generell
wenn dann nicht irgendwie eine falle doof erwischt das eigentlich allgemein ist das
kein großes problem
das brauche ich in 38 38 38 dann machen wir doch noch hier weiter haben wir noch die die
kampagne weiter ich bin ja froh dass ich mittlerweile zum größten teil die kampagne auswendig kann
wenn ich permanent geil gucken müsste dann wirst verrückt im kopf das ist beide in super
gebiet um kurz zwischendurch zu leveln vielleicht dann plus ein scam ja hab ich glaube ich
sogar irgendwo noch gucken was der kram kostet dürfte die welt kosten ich meine die scheiß
auf die anderen stats na guck ich gleich mal was das kostet das ist eine gute idee schneller
zu kaufen als dass ich den kram da in meiner kiste gesucht habe falls ich überhaupt ans
hab wir können eine wand und ein schild kaufen ich meine who cares dafür habe ich genug
wäre am start wo es halt richtig teuer wird ist dann die kombination plus all scale gems
und chaos gems huge boss clear pot potential hier aber zum glück sind die kampagnenbosse
alle easy mode warum ist denn dahin ich klinge oben noch mal kurz den anderen kram das gibt
nämlich instant level ab instant level ab dann gucken wir mal kurz auf der trade seite
ich hab jetzt schon die ganze zeit das ist das ist das letzte was wir machen das ist
das letzte was wir machen aber irgendwie habe ich keinen bock aufzuhören das ist das was
ich bei pesto weg sei im vergleich zu irgendwie die upload 3 halt hab ich höre nicht auf
zu spielen
komm level up please war schnell chaos multiplier kriege ich auch im skilltree auf jeden fall
noch massig klar aber auf equip schadet natürlich auch nicht level ab level ab komm mal schnell
auf der trade seite poe poggers komm mal schnell auf der trade seite trade also wir suchen wie
ist das chaos skill gems ok moment moment moment also war ich what the fuck soviel wollte
ich jetzt für level item eigentlich nicht ausgeben category want moment ich suche nach
dem falschen oder chaos spell gems muss ich suchen ah ja da kommt eine sache ich hab mich
falsch gesucht
das hier ist doch ganz gut das ist doch ganz nett achso min level oh lolololol moment
2 max level da kommt man der sache schon näher ich bin 34
gibt es auch noch mit spell damage gibt es gibt es die kombi
chaos multiplier nee chaos oh wie heißt denn der kram chaos increase over time multiplier
da wirds teuer da wirds teuer nee das machen wir nicht und auf dem schild gibt es das auch
mal schild das ist gar nicht übel naja all elemental resistance es könnte doch ein bisschen
mehr spell damage haben vielleicht was es hier noch mit spell damage gibt spell damage
spell damage explicit
das ist gut das ist gut
aus meiner kiste das ist gut andere kram ist so zu teuer
mal glück dass es kein afk dude ist
3 gait lul kann man das nicht lul der passt exzellent
oh hat er mich gescampt
wait a minute hat er mich gescampt hat er mich gescampt ah nee autoequip lul ich hab
schon gerade hab ich gescampt alter autoequip alter gbait
das ist ey das schild ist nicht nicht übel ja
ok nice so und jetzt noch ne wand jetzt noch ne wand
da gibt es bestimmt nix neues jetzt oh das ist ja nice das wollen wir haben
das ist bestimmt gbait angeboten
du got gbaited na komm scheiß drauf hab genug oh oh nee nee
easy
nice nice haben wir richtig krasse items für ein paar chaos gekriegt also was heißt richtig
krasse aber ziemlich gute items so dann werden wir das gerade mal kurz färben
das ist ja auch schon 3 length a color a common a big damage boost
ah jetzt hier poggers huge boost so 34 auf gehts weiter
naja also für den preis kann man sich nicht beschweren was wir da gekriegt haben oh man
ist schon ok ist jetzt kein op shit oder so ne für 2 chaos kannst du dir eh nicht beschweren
mit 38 gehts dann richtig ab ich glaube 38 mache ich noch ich will sehen wie das wie
das flutscht hier mit projectiles ich meine es geht guck mal hier das macht übelst
damage jetzt schon mit multiple projectiles gehts noch mehr ab
es macht schon ganz gut damage jetzt muss man sagen
max wieso hast du das spellslinger gem 3 mal gekauft weil ich 3 mal brauche ich brauch
es einmal in dem setup hier ich brauch es in dem setup hier und ich brauchs in dem setup
hier also spellslinger ist ja kein aktiver skill was spellslinger macht ist also vielleicht
mal kurz erklären spellslinger nimmt die skills die mit ihm gelingt sind reserviert mana dafür
und bei jeder attack die man macht mit seiner waffe lösen dann automatisch die spells aus
was die mit spellslinger gelingt sind also ich caste die spells nicht ich klick eigentlich
nur attack dadurch dass ich attack klicke löst spellslinger einmal solrent aus einmal
essence drain aus und einmal contagion aus ja und umso weiter man spellslinger auflevelt
umso mehr damage konvertiert das von physical was die waffe hat zu magic was spells haben
und deswegen hab ich 3 spellslinger gekauft jetzt muss ich mal gucken hier ist irgendwo
noch so ein mob so irgendein fiech das man befreien muss für den skillpoint wo ist es
denn irgendwo ist hier noch so ein fiech was man für den skillpoint befreien muss dann
eventuell noch witch pur anstatt mana flask weiß ich gar nicht was das macht was macht
das denn weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht eins ist despair curse despair hole ich mir gleich
mit casts ja kommt in die schuhe oder warte mal kommt in wo kommt es denn überhaupt rein
hier kommt in die schuhe rein curse und hit despair sobald ich 38 bin weiß ich ob das
dann nicht ein bisschen doppelt gemobbelt ist ach da ist das fies ja alles besser als
eine mana flaske hast du recht die mana flaske brauche ich wirklich nicht aber ich hab immer
ganz gerne noch eine dabei zumindest am anfang bist du noch ein bisschen mehr rack hab aber
ich brauch sie eigentlich weil hast du schon recht falls es doch mal ausgeht aber das wird
nicht ausgehen das mana gerade mit essence train jetzt wenn es noch besser wird eigentlich
sinnlos ja stimmt schon eigentlich sinnlos
by the way wie sieht das stream bei euch aus mit ich hab 7900p eingestellt es müsste eigentlich
ziemlich gut aussehen hallo sterben please 7900k nicht 7900p naja komm linus hat letztens
mit 8k gespielt da kann ich auch mit 7900k spielen 7900p krispy clear ja leider ist halt
das internet in deutschland so kacke ne dass es eventuell ein paar gibt wo das stream rocket
deswegen
ne 7900k klingt fast wie ein intel cpu ist weniger nee schwachsinn keine ahnung was ich
gerade von mir gebe er gibt eigentlich überhaupt was ich gerade erzähle ja das ist schon richtig
habt ihr gut erkannt
hier richtig richtig speedrun klicks annele geht ab heftig what map ich sag bloß
da oben rechts gehts lang monkaS wer soll das denn sehen hallo na click da kippen so um
flutscht richtig jetzt hier seitdem wir auf spellslinger umgestellt haben aber das ist
ja auch ziemlich ziemlich im meta spekt zum leveln gerade
ja das sind wir exquisite ach jetzt kommt das zeug genau das ist eigentlich auch easy
as fuck
ich bräuchte pleat und curse immune of flasks was das mein was da getroppt crap lull brauche
ich alles nett wenn ich daran erinnere es gab ja am anfang keine lootfilter dass der
bildschirm war voll mit mit crap items und du wusstest gar nicht was du aufheben musstest
das spiel hat am anfang auch noch nicht mal sechs links richtig angezeigt du musstest
jeden müll angucken in der hoffnung es ist da mal irgendwo nen ich kenne ich sechs links
sie sind sehr selten sechs ockels dabei und sowas
was das ist
lightning cold
attack rate ist halt praktisch jetzt mit spellslinger
ach ne jetzt funktioniert ja autorun nicht 69 zuschauer
gachi bass
nimm mich raus lassen hier please
was sag mal gehts hier vielleicht
was da hä
muss man hier alles killen das weiter geht
kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern dass das hier notwendig war
oder bin ich schlicht erkannt ich glaube ich bin falsch gelaufen hier gehts nicht weiter
hier ist ja auch keine tür oder sonst was
ne falsche falsche richtung lull
die baited
passiert mir laufen
ich hatte hier immer glück bisher
war mir gar nicht so klar dass man hier überhaupt richtig falsch laufen kann
ja immer das gelaber gar nicht anhören
lore lull
bei der weide spieler übrigens in story wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat
aber eine ziemlich schlechte
also ich glaube passiv exe alles echten spieler spielt niemand für die story
man merkt auch richtig dass die vom anfang an kein plan wo wo wo
monka kein plan hatten was sie eigentlich machen wollten
das passt doch überhaupt nicht zusammen das ist ganze wir also die story ist wirklich
nicht die nicht die stärke dieses spiel
mal gucken was in passiv exe als zwei machen diesmal wissen sie aber ungefähr was auf
dazu kommt ich will ihnen mal nicht die fähigkeit absprengen gescheite stories zu schreiben
aber die passiv exe als story ist nicht ist
oh was war was war das was er gerade getroppt
jetzt ist ja mal gut ah guck mal oh exzellent
sister hat sich auch gelohnt zu sterben
ok irgendwie weiß ich dass jetzt gelohnt hat ein chaos ob mehr zu haben
weil ich 5000 oder so nee nicht ganz macht es auch nicht fett
einfach mal durchs town portal durch geflitzt ist
spielst du vd spellslinger necro nee also als ich hab ich hab hier einen die leakier
den da den da wupps nee das ist nur zum leveln das gibt
den cast on grid ice nova aber
ich level jetzt erst mal mit chaos chaos spellslinger
bis so keine ahnung 70 oder so 75
weil das einfach sich total easy und schnell leveln lässt
dann gebe ich lieber ein bisschen geld aus für respect
komm die gegner können überhaupt nichts machen die kriegen mega auf den sack
einmal drauf gecasted down
die können nicht mal spawnen das sind die schon tot
ok zack
warum hast du das nicht aufgepickt
regrets sind immer ja ich hab erstens noch jede menge
und ja das schon recht man kann sich auch easy kaufen
da gebe ich lieber irgendwie 30 respect points normaltöslich aus
um zu respekten bevor ich mich da irgendwie rum quäle
und mit irgendeinem müll level
außerdem macht spellslinger level unglaublich spaß
das glaube ich eines der spaßigsten level builds die man so machen kann in dem spiel
also auch auch dings hier wd necoding ist auch macht auch
übelst bock
zu leveln
nicht wd vd
volatile dead
ich finde spellslinger macht übelst spaß zu leveln
was ist es verschenkt im chat lasagne
und jetzt bin ich verwirrt chat
außerdem geht es hier nicht weiter
du liest den im chat nein ich liest den im chat nicht
der in game chat ist meistens trolls die trolle trollen so und ab und zu mal ein bisschen
toxik geflame
eigentlich müsste ich den in game chat ausplenden
sogar
weil dort manchmal die ein oder andere sachen etwas nicht ganz so twitch tostkonforme sachen
geschrieben werden
geht um lasagne
ja das game ist free to play
muss ich einloggen muss ich ihm schreiben
was wurscht ihr das mit lasagne
chat
und ks
vielleicht soll ich mal specken ne runde
äh wo sind wir noch stehen geblieben hier
hier mal hoch
ich specke mal zu dem
wo ist das
zu dem juwelensocke
das können wir garantiert gleich gebrauchen für irgendwas
jetzt ist die frage gehen wir erst zu den chaos damage nodes hoch
oder wir gehen zu den chaos damage
alles was man killt kann dich nicht mehr killen ist doch ganz einfach
wobei die hier sind auch nicht schlecht egal
alterations sind die league irgendwie ziemlich teuer
warum eigentlich
das stimmt nuke das wirklich ab wobei poe läuft was schön läuft läuft fast überall
wahrscheinlich sogar auf nintendo ds
das wärs noch poe ds port
eigentlich wäre das mal jetzt mal leute ehrlich das wäre ein geiler ds port oder
poe mobile auf dem ds wäre doch echt nice
ich weiß es kommt es kommt jetzt demnächst ja richtiges mobile
also nicht auf dem auf dem auf dem auf dem neueren ds
wird dann custom kri- ja wirds
aber ich muss mir noch gear kaufen
ich habe ein bisschen reserve
aber mal gucken wie weit ich komm
ich hoffe dass ich mit 2-3 exiles ein halbwegs budget build hinkriege
dass ich nicht meinen ganzen krempel da reinhauen muss
aber wo gehts denn lang hier
schon eine ach nee mein atlas sieht traurig aus den zeige ich dir nicht
das sieht übelst traurig aus
so game wo gehts denn jetzt lang kann euch sein ich renn hier nur in sackgassen gerade
hier ah exzellent
die map hat extrem viele magic packs
ist ja gut
so wir kann jetzt meine güte
der willst aber wissen
du bist gerade am überlegen dir einen neuen pc zu holen
ja also ich bin ja auch schon am überlegen
die ganze zeit seit ende letzten jahres mir einen pc zu holen
aber es lohnt sich nicht zu upgraden
deswegen spekuliere ich drauf dass amd ende des jahres
oder nicht ende des jahres
dass amd jetzt demnächst hoffentlich mal bald mit 9 cpus vorbeikommt
die intel wirklich komplett im regen stehen lassen
und dass nvidia endlich mit ner neuen grafikkarten generation um die ecke kommt
dann kaufe ich mir auch wieder ein
weil aktuell lohnt es sich einfach nicht
mir juckt es
ohne scherz mir juckt es in den fingern seit
letztes jahr die neuen ryzen rausgekommen sind mir einen zu kaufen
aber es lohnt sich halt 0
vor allem 8700k
wenns darum geht kann man immer warten
ja man kann auch sinnlos sein geld ausgeben
es lohnt sich halt nicht
ich sehs nicht ein
auch wenn man die kohle hat
ich sehs nicht ein irgendwie 3000 euro oder so auszugeben für ein rechner
der
15 prozent schneller ist als mein alter
das ist doch
doch müll
gibt es bei dem spiel immer so liegen für eine gewisse zeit oder wenn ein spiel beginnt
open end beides
es gibt alle drei monaten ungefähr eine neue league mit neuer mechanik
also sprich jede league ist ein bisschen anders
diesmal kann man besonders gut craften
und es gibt aber auch wenn man nicht möchte wenn man keine liga spielen will
kann man auch standard open end spielen
standard open end hat
den vor und nachteil
du hast also du hast keine league mechaniken
manche leute mögen das nicht
und du hast halt high end items die sind ein bisschen besser available
dafür musste da auch erst mal ein currency kommen
in standard
der michael 50.000.000 ist am start moin auch mal wieder am start
pock
erst
pock like this
sind wir eigentlich 38
ha ha
leute wir sind 38 wir können upgraden
pockers jetzt
jetzt gehts ab hier
jetzt wird das build noch mehr op
moment wo ist hier mein mein
frenzy frenzy
zack
moment
was brauche ich in frenzy
curse on hit
curse on hit faster attacks
faster attacks
curse on hits
dis
schreibt man das
despair nicht despair
des des bear
jop
moment wir müssen kurz das ganze mal ein bisschen umwürsten
so
ha
despair
hopp nein damit
so wer kriegt multiple projectiles
so rent
wo haben wir so rent drinne
wait a minute
wir verteidigen das jetzt am besten
kannst du den payspin in den chat kopieren
äh ja
äh
moment
wie gesagt ist nicht von mir hab ich mir auch noch abgeguckt
hab ich noch hab ich noch was brauche ich noch ich brauche ein 4 link oder brauche
ich noch ein 4 link
so rent creator multiple projectiles
ok also den kram hier habe ich fertig
wo soll denn überhaupt jetzt ich bin jetzt gerade mal
warte mal ich bin jetzt gerade fehl
wo kommt jetzt increased area support nochmal dabei
ah
contagion ok contagion kommt dann hier rein
increased area
increased area support
so und jetzt fehlt mir noch
soul rent
spellslinger
und multiple projectiles oder
genau so wo kriege ich denn das
wo kriege ich denn das jetzt rein
das muss ich ja eigentlich die handschuhe
also habe ich irgendwelche handschuhe wo der kram reinpasst
monkaS
gloves
ich brauche grün
grün blau blau blau
gucken wir ob ich noch so was hab wenn ich muss ich noch ein bisschen
vielleicht warte ich einfach bis 41
sind immer lang
aber ja schnell
oder aber
den krab den will ich da will ich keine currency für ausgeben
was kauf du e tritt echt
zeig mal ja
trade
ja der kurs
koala sound kennt sich aus
das ist cool
so und das ganze jetzt allerdings bitteschön noch mit
drei ne drei blau ein grün
und vier links
easy ja komm mal her whisper
lull also dafür da mache ich mir doch gar kein kopp
da ist immer nächste
oh der nächste kostet schon 5
ok also wenn der mir das für ein verkauft dann ist aber das ist
tibet angebot
das ist tibet angebot
der will triggern dass die leute ihm das verkaufen dafür
oder pro
komm ich geb dafür auf fünf aus mir doch egal
ich hab genug juckt mich überhaupt nicht
stimmt color sockets den einfach mal gucken ob der jetzt wenn der mich
entweidet dann mache ich es ansonsten
welcher war das jetzt
den tür habe ich auch nicht angewespert
oder auch beim falschen den habe ich angewespert
ja hast recht lohnt sich wahrscheinlich echt nicht aber ist doch wurscht gehts jetzt direkt
weiter
wo ist immer stehen geblieben
was ein chaos in 2000 chrome echt jetzt so viel
moment warte mal da musst du grad mal kurz gucken
kann er jetzt sein hier gar nicht mal
ja genug ich habe ja auch noch genug
aber wurscht passt
fire resistance kann man ein bisschen drauf machen also haben wir den kram zack zack zack
zack
so irgendwo haben wir noch ein bisschen fire resistance wo können wir noch mal schnell
fire resistance drauf machen
strength brauchen wir nicht
irgendwo irgendwo hier mal schnell mal fire resistance drauf
ein bisschen fire resistance kann nichts schaden
noch mal schnell noch mal dass uns nicht irgendwas killt
ah billigste von billigen ist der crab ring
stimmt ja auf level requirement habe ich nicht geguckt
ein bisschen glück gehört dabei so jetzt sind wir noch ziemlich gut equipped alles
fast max
ist mein portal aus meinem portal hin
ach ne ich hab gequittet oder
was
moment jetzt sag bloß mir fehlt jetzt mana
nein
moment moment ich muss things specken
ah mana reservation mana reservation gab es doch hier
habe ich nicht geskillt wo war mana reservation
ja da muss ich hin
ok ein level noch ein level hat man so aus
aber dann gibts ultra damage nachdem wir sind ja hier fast durch
guck mal wie schnell die xp geht
oh ich hab meinen flame dash vergessen
no
hab meinen flame dash vergessen
na michael da bin ich ja froh dass du da bist
flame
es geht entleiten mit spellslinger es geht nur es gehen nur aktive sachen mit spellslinger
aber du kannst die aktiven sachen mit einem support gem supporten
aber du musst gucken dass die mana reservation hinhaut
achso ich nee bei mir reicht die mana reservation nicht mehr
ich krieg jetzt ja schon nicht mehr alles raus
das problem ist dass hier umso mehr support gems du drin hast umso mehr mana reserviert
das
achso mit entleiten könnte sein ja
aber die kombi ist jetzt echt top
wie gesagt mir fehlt ja noch ein skill noch für das für ein level brauche ich noch dann
gibt es noch mana reservierung
wait a minute ist das genau die gleiche map wie eben
wirkt so
habt ihr kurz noch nicht gerade triggern sehen
au annele
ja das mit entleiten könnte man echt machen
wobei ich keins mehr hab ich hab die alle gesellt
aber guck mal ich bin fürs leveln hier
ich hab alle gesellt ich hab glück gehabt ich hab relativ viele getroppt
ich hab glaub drei
drei rote entleiten dinger getroppt
ich hab ich habe getroppt ist eigentlich auch so ein dämliche
rede wendung die eigentlich gar keinen sinn ergibt
und zwei blaue
übelst lucky gewesen also gleich am anfang von der league wovon ich dann mein necro ausrüsten
konnte
so jetzt please level ab dass ich mana reservation machen kann
also ganz ganz ohne
ach stimmt stimmt stimmt ja ja du hast recht dann halt ich dir ja klar
blaues entleiten genau
so mana reservation
ha
Increased area mal raus das ist nicht so wild
Manacraft bringt nichts ist Prozent
Warte mal doch das müsste
Das müsste glaube ich was bringen ich glaube nicht dass es 100 Prozent Reservierung sind
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es eine abrunde abrundgeschichte oder so sind wir ja gleich
Ach nee oder der nächste skill reduziert vielleicht noch mehr warte mal
Let's gucken passives
Guck mal der nächste macht acht prozent ja dann ist klar ja dann ist easy
Wenn der nächste noch mal acht prozent macht dann habe ich überhaupt kein kein
Problem
Dann ist easy as fuck
Hätte ich gleich immer am Anfang skilln sollen ich hab nicht darauf geachtet
Dass da unten die skillnodes gibt
Und dass man die braucht
Alter die map die jebaitet mich ja hart gerade
Überall wo ich denke das weiter geht geht nicht weiter
Die habe ich bei Porkbun gekauft mich in die domains
Allerdings hat Porkbun keine
DNS API
Deswegen haben die mich ja gesperrt weil ich versucht habe ihre Webseite Webseite zu
Skripten das hat ihnen nicht gepasst
Aber die sind halt echt billig Porkbun
Und zum hosten ich hauste nichts extern
Wenn ich mal was brauche mache ich mir eine digital ocean vm alter die map jebaitet krass
Mache ich mir eine digital ocean vm auf die schnelle wobei ich ihn jetzt eher zu hetzener
cloud tendiere sogar
Also die nächste nächste mal wenn ich open street view maps preprocessen muss kauf ich
mir eine hetzener cloud vm
Und ja wenn ich was hosten würde würde ich es wahrscheinlich auch hetzener cloud kaufen
Kommt halt drauf an was du
Excellent der raum war ist sehr sinnvoll
Sagt mal
Sagt bloß da also die map ist wirklich gerade der wahnsinn
Also falsche hätte man nicht laufen können überall immer sackgasse
Ich muss schon sagen spellslinger level macht echt mega bock
Moment hier kann es nicht lang gehen das hätte ich von der anderen seite gesehen
So jetzt please lass mir mal den weg finden
Wann hast du das letzte mal die upload 3 gespielt
Vor 2 jahren oder so
Ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen dass ich da so grundlegend noch was getan hat
Oder?
Hat sich?
Weiß nicht
Kannst du mir nicht vorstellen
Moin doppelfelix98
Mein rifts und das ganze gedöns mit self found kenne ich ja schon
Den boss habe ich am anfang nie gecheckt
Dabei muss man einfach nur hinter der rumlaufen und es passiert einem nichts
Oh okay also
Außer das
Jetzt ist er mal gut
Er ist groß gelabert und dann fast verreckt
Grundlegend hat sich nichts geärgert
Also wie gesagt die rift geschichte habe ich in die upload 3 noch mitgekriegt
Dass es jetzt self found only ist habe ich auch noch mitgekriegt
Das war es im großen und ganzen und die rifts haben mir überhaupt nicht gefallen
Ja ich verstehe dass rifts und maps nicht so großartig unterschiedlich sind
Ich meine rifts hat verschiedene ebenen
Das ist ein bisschen wie delve so in die richtung irgendwie die rift geschichte
Aber was mir in rifts überhaupt nicht gefallen hat dass es alles so hässliche extrem bunte
Hüllen waren irgendwie
Da war vom normalen game überhaupt nichts da mehr übrig
Außer ihm hat mir die upload 3 von anfang an nicht gut gefallen
Ich brauche by the way ich bräuchte mal ich bräuchte mal ne
Portal scroll ich bräuchte mal ein bisschen portal scrolls
Oder besser gesagt ich müsste die mal aufnehmen
By the way warum renne ich eigentlich an den boss fights vorbei ich schenke blieb
Ja weil ich irgendwie nach portal scrolls geguckt habe voll bescheuert
Jetzt schreckt
Ich brauche ein portal
Diese bosse hier ne die sind recycelt as fuck
Die kommen hier am start die kommen später der kommt
Ich glaube der kommt sogar viermal der dude hier
Der kommt in der map dann später nochmal und am ende nochmal
Also boss recycling vom feinsten was sie hier abgeliefert haben
Mach auge chat macht auge
Aber der verreck ich immer weil der nicht weiß wo ich mich hinstellen muss
Oder könnte mal please eine portal scroll droppen
Oder ist das grad nicht im rng vorhanden
Jedoch zum waypoint ja kann ich kann ich auch machen
Aber trotzdem warum gibt es keine portal scrolls
Der ganze dungeon hatte keine portal scrolls
Und ich drücke immer schon alle zwischendurch
Falls mein loot filter spackt oder so das gibt nix
Nee ich hab den normalen strict filter da ist das ist da eigentlich drinnen
Wartet mal ich hätte ich hätte gern noch ein level
Irgendwas mir vollkommen egal ein level weil da kann ich das wieder rein zocken
Ah if level einfach nur ein level ja mehr kaum was
Oh nee jetzt lauf ich auch noch raus Nee oder auch nicht oder was oder doch oder
aah monkaS
Wenn du länger als echt jetzt klaustest dann nee
Nee ich hab den waypoint ich hab mit piety geredet
Darf ich nicht nochmal machen oder oh nee ich komm auch nicht mehr zurück
Echt okay dann mach ich dann mach ich das jetzt
Ist okay aber ich brauch nicht länger als 10 minuten
Komm mal wieso ich sag ich hab jetzt level up
Okay fast jetzt jetzt hab ich level up
Meine Güte jetzt hab ich level up level up level up jetzt hab ich level up
So jetzt porten wir zurück
By the way scrolls scrolls sind out
Weil kann ich den kram wieder aktivieren
Mal die reservierung crepen und increased area wieder rein machen
Und ich hab ganze 37 mana poggers
Und jetzt werden wir den boss bashen
Auf labern nicht so viel lass ich killen
Big brain boss der gleich stirbt
Oh nee ach das ist dieser
So jetzt aber
Ich mach zu viel damage die mechanics wollen nicht mitmachen
Ah jetzt haben wirs
Der war schon fast down aber die mechanics von dem fight haben gesagt nope du musst
jetzt
Weil ich hab immer noch keine portal scroll
Aber wenn man stirbt passiert ja nichts
Also wenn man stirbt wird er direkt wieder gespawnt
Ja ja bla bla bla
Damit tentakel monstert wieder
So jetzt aber get shrecked
Es fährt erstmal im fahrstuhl runter
So please sterben
Jetzt exzellent alles selten klar
Wobei warum brauch nix ich hab genug
So akt 4 fertig oder
Akt 5 äh moment welcher akt ist das 4
4 ne 4 war das jetzt
Verwirrt mich immer die irgendwann
Ich nach 3 ich kann nicht weiter als 3 zählen
So jetzt muss ich erstmal noch ein paar skills und gedöns abholen
Hier von dem krieg ich schon skill book
Hier muss ich noch ein skill book abholen
Hier oben krieg ich jetzt glaube ich noch irgendwelche gems die ich nicht brauche
Ach guck mal jetzt increased area gekriegt
Alles nett kann ich aber zu allen fall eh kaufen
So jetzt muss ich noch den berg hoch und dann ist der akt vorbei
Und chat ich sag euch es ist viel später geworden als ich eigentlich vor hatte
Guck mal hier jetzt das ist der clear speed ist so krass in der kampagne
Einfach geradeaus laufen cast und alles stirbt
Ach man muss irgendwo hin drücken ok
Für die speedruns ja grundstein ist gelegt ne
Das speedrun meta build hab ich ja schon mal drauf hier
Muss noch ein bisschen besser werden zu erkennen wo es auf den karten lang geht
Ich hab ja ehrlich gesagt keine großartige speedrun ambition aber ich würde gerne auch
für zukünftige leagues einfach die kampagne schnell durchkriegen
Auch das hier ist ja auch ein super starter build letztendlich
Da war ein tp scroll die neuen exhalts
Jetzt zu spät Jetzt zu spät
Ok erst tp scroll wo ist mein tp scroll tp scroll
Habt ihr es gesehen ich hab eine portal scroll
Also als es neu war ging das game nur bis zu dem fight im lunaris temple gegen piety
Danach war es Schluss also als inner beta
Danach kam irgendwann dominus das ist dieser typ auf dem dach der sich dann in so ein demon
verwandelt hat und dann war fertig Die ganzen acts kamen erst später
Letzte season um die 25 exhalts auf einem char verbraten irgendwie null ambition für
die season gehabt Ja ich hab letzte season hab ich nicht gespielt
hatte ich irgendwie auch keinen bock Ich finde aber eigentlich gerade die motivation
dadurch dass ich das gesettet zumindest hilft das bei mir
Aber bei 25 exhalts auf der hohen kante bin ich bin ich grad noch nicht
Ich hab grad glaub nur 500 ruhe Da muss ich noch ein bisschen farm
Und bisschen zeug verkaufen Ja ich bin auch kein fan von harvest ich
kräfte auch nicht gerne Aber warum mir persönlich harvest trotzdem
gefällt ist das so extrem krasses gear also irgendwie chests mit exploding
also wenn die gegner explodieren und dann gewisse prozent zahl physical damage machen
gepaart mit reflect immunity und so was das waren halt mega krasse dinger und die sind
jetzt relativ häufig das heißt wenn man es so macht wie wir im endeffekt wenn man harvest
nicht mag verkauft man einfach seine seeds weil die seeds bringen fette Kohle und kauft
sich die Sachen die andere gecraftet haben ich mag harvest auch nicht aber es sorgt dafür
dass so richtig übertrieben geile items mehr vorhanden sind das finde ich gut und wenn
man selbst lieber lieber hier kreisel grindet und farmen anstatt zu craften kann man die
sich auch kaufen indem man seeds verkauft also man macht massig Kohle mit seeds verkaufen
man kann aktuell item level 76 plus seeds verkaufen für mindestens 0,3 c pro seed also
ich hab ich hab heute morgen über das muss man leider muss man leider mit discord machen
weil es die offizielle trading seite nicht unterstützt bulk verkauf von seeds ich habe
heute morgen ungefähr 1500 1500 what the fuck ja 1500 seeds verkauft das war ungefähr
die hälfte von dem was ich hab mal 0,3 und das war schon echt billig man hätte da durchaus
0,35 oder so rausholen können das waren dann ungefähr 450 chaos das sind 3,66 holes einfach
für ein bisschen seeds gefarme und jetzt habe ich noch mal so viel ungefähr 81 plus seeds
die versuche ich für 0,4 zu verkaufen äh delirium habe ich nicht gespielt habe ich
aber auch gelesen dass das wohl ziemliche abfuck für einige war ja also kann ich verstehen
dass das ziemliche abfuck für einige war delirium also ich kenne ja die delirium mechanik
die gibt es ja jetzt auch auf den normalen maps 1 gdo was ist denn das hier eigentlich
irgendwelche pets von leuten ja ich sehe so richtig low aus alle guckt mal ich sehe so
richtig low aus ich könnte wenigstens mal microtransactions drauf machen diese hässliche
mütz guckt euch mal an das sieht so schlecht aus so ein schlafanzug hemmt und so eine mütz
auf also was passiert mit chars wenn die season endet dann werden die charaktere nach standard
kopiert du kannst weiter spielen allerdings natürlich nicht in der nächsten season weil
nächste season der nächste season ist halt wie habe ich das geschafft dass ich nur noch
einen übrig habe aber genau einen das muss man erst mal schaffen das ist auch so was
was ich nicht ganz verstehe ist warum haben die hier keine suche im shop in game wenn ich
jetzt nach pets suchen will und nach den gartenzwergen kann ich hier gar nicht suchen
richtig ok wenigstens irgendwas irgendwas ausrüsten ja habe ich nix für in use aber
ich habe es schon gekippt ach so weil es ein weapon ist dass der effekt immer nur man
macht es auch nicht besser oder ok das sieht jetzt sogar ganz gut aus da passt es aber
das engel schild nicht wirklich zu na so erst erst mal ein bisschen microtransactions ausrüsten
ja also ohne geht ja nicht so gut jetzt machen wir jetzt ein bisschen was sehr optisch und
filter microtransactions bin ich blind
ach da what the fuck
das ist mir ach hier ist das gar nicht
ok pets da war so der dwarf ne wie heißen die dinger dann ich fand die übelst nice
aber ich kann es mir nicht kaufen weil ich habe nur noch einen punkt
ach ja paar pflügel pflügel pflügel brauchen wir auch noch pflügel brauchen wir auch noch oder
warum warum hat das ding waffen auf dem rücken die ich überhaupt nicht habe das gefällt mir
nicht das sagt dann lieber dann lieber pflügel dabei das ist der kombi was der scheiß kombi
vorne wird gebrannt und der rest leuchtet was gibt es für essen strain mein plan excellent
ja gut ok leute es reicht für heute genug was haben wir hier played vier stunden naja
hälfte vom game und fest durch hälfte vom game durch nach acht stunden kampagne null speedrun
please aber sind wir noch ungefähr ja hälfte kommt hin oder die akte die jetzt kommen also
außerdem akt der akt ist dauert jetzt noch ein bisschen aber die ganzen also akt 6 7 8 9 10 das
ist ja teilweise mehr oder weniger geradlinig ist durchgerennen was schlecht das fünf oder so
ja diese leak ist krass
also mit seeds verkaufen man kann übels kohle machen ich habe das überhaupt nicht optimiert
betrieben jetzt also ich habe mir da nie gedanken darüber gemacht habe das alles
gehortet ja richtig dumm mit dem also gerade mit seeds fahren kannst du übels kohle machen gerade
du hast ja teilweise sie sind bis zu 15 20 chaos wert für das übelste ich ja und ansonsten also ich
habe letztens ein video gesehen von einem der hat eine auswertung gefahren mit mit drops über
glaube 5 6 oder irgendwie einen tag fahren und er ist auf glaube ich 900 chaos die stunde gekommen
das halt echt heftig überlegt auf so viel wenn du überlegst dass es komplett high end content
und auch ein ordentliches high end equip und bild braucht dass du das machen kannst das sind ja
ungefähr dann das chaos sind 130 g runden wir mal auf sieben exhalts die stunde das ist schon
ordentlich aber wenn du dir vorstellst dass dann auch manchmal richtig krasse sachen troppen und
vielleicht steht man doch auf das gekraftet man kann da schon ordentlich currency machen wenn
man das optimiert betreibt mein scheiß ultra high end gerade der 41 also mein main geht sogar
mein main ist gar nicht so schlecht hier der hier wobei stehen mal ich müsste mal richtig ohne ohne
ohne boss zu machen weil bei den verreck ich manchmal also der ist bei weitem nicht perfekt
ja also ich brauche auf jeden fall noch unbedingt mehr einen besseren helm weil der sack ziemlich
ich brauche einen helm der mana reservierung macht und noch ein bisschen mehr life gibt die
chest ist ganz nice und ansonsten habe sogar ein portal drin die boots sind auch nicht so
dolle das darf es ganz ok also das ist alles kein krasses high end zeug die chest ist aber
ganz nice die chester bezahlt auch ganz gut was für wobei ist ziemlich getroppt im preis
nicht getroppt na gut leute ich gehe jetzt ins bet pen morgen früh aufwachen stream ich hoffe
ich hat es gefallen bis denn wir sehen uns macht's gut zu